all
right as chair of the house Ways and
Means Committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a commit meeting
for the purpose of receiving agency
Revenue
presentations please note that there is
no physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporar to this meeting however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate cont
temporarly during the meeting through
the zoom electronic meeting platform and
the public has access to
contemporarily listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with health rules RSA
911-a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS l.st do. Us in the event the public
is unable to access this meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us which is Christopher Shay from the
LBA and Brad
Greenland
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll
call let's start the meeting by taking
the roll call attendance when each
member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no law and
there's one more thing I would like to
ask that you state that
Thursday we'll be holding a public
hearing for seven bills at the
lobb and
is we want to know whether you're going
to be attending virtually or personally
so when you do answer the role if you
would indicate that so representative
brahney can make a note of this because
there's not room for everybody to attend
personally
so um if you can attend virtually that's
fine so
representative Bernstein would you take
the
role you got to unmute um Alan you got
to
unmute thank you apologies
representative of brown
yes I'm here in stratum alone and I will
be attending Thursday in
Mary well Mary's figuring that out let's
move on to representative
oy present uh in my office alone my
wife's in the house and uh I'll virtual
on Thursday say virtual virtual okay
thank you and and representative can you
turn up your your speaker volume that
would help to go ahead representative uh
representative
Thursday representative
ducet good morning uh alone in my home
office in Salem and I look forward to
seeing you in person on
Thursday excellent your clerk is
representative Buren and I'm in my home
office in Nottingham there might be a
dog or two in the room and I plan on
attending in person on Thursday
representative
yourself representative Elliott unmute
yourself and tell us you're
here
you're still muted representative
Elliott Brad can you help him
out a
help ask him to
unmute Elli can can you hear me now yes
unmuted on Thursday will you be there in
person or virtually
virtual representative janig
janigian well said I'm uh in my home in
Salem New Hampshire my wife and daughter
are somewhere in the house I will attend
virtually on
Thursday representative
Nunes representative ative
Nunes representative
Baxter thank you representative um I'm
here alone and I'm going to attend
virtually on
Thursday representative spillsbury
I'm here at my home alone in Charlestown
New Hampshire and plan to attend in
person
Thursday representative
Tudor I'm here alone and my Sol wife and
grandkids are upstairs is and I'll be
attending virtually on
Thursday representative
Aly I'm home alone in Lebanon and I will
be
virtual representative
in yeah hi I'm here in Jeffrey alone in
my office and I will attend virtually on
Thursday thank you representative
Southworth hi representative Southworth
I'm home alone in Dover and I'll be
attending
virtually representative
Malloy I'm home alone in Greenland and I
will be attending
virtually representative
shamberg uh I'm in my truck and wilmet
and I will be
attending the meeting
personally representative Tucker yes I'm
alone in
Randolph and I plan to be virtually
present on Thursday slightly late I'm um
testifying before public works at
9:30 representative
garlo I am here in Swansea alone and
I'll attend virtually on
Thursday representative
lofman representative
gorg good morning I am in my home in Lee
by myself and I will be virtual on
Thursday thank you representative hacken
hacken Phillips morning I'm present in
my concerete office alone uh I'm
planning to attend virtually on Thursday
as well representative Murphy morning I
am present here in Handover in my house
my wife and daughter are elsewhere in
the home and I will be attending
virtually on Thursday representative
major I'm here in my house my uh wife is
in the other room and I will be
present okay and let's go back to
representative Griffin
um Brad can you remind Mary how to
unmute herself on the phone is it I
unmute good morning Mary good morning
how are you I'm fine thank you on
Thursday do you plan on uh attending
virtually or in
person uh in person I believe
excellent okay that completes the roll
call there are 22 of us here two are
absent thank
you okay we have a very busy day today
we
have eight presentations from the
various
agencies um starting with the
legislative budget system office Then
followed by Department of Revenue
Lottery Commission Liquor Commission
this morning this afternoon the judicial
branch Department of Health Human
Services Security Bureau and the
Department of Justice and
tomorrow we'll be hearing from the
insurance department Department of
Safety
Department of Transportation Fish and
Game Commission Department of
administrative services and the treasury
Department each one of these presenters
will be
presenting
virtually and we'll start off with the
office of legislative budget assistant
and Chris
Shay good morning uh chairman major and
committee um my purpose today to speak
with you is to be very brief because we
got Dr coming on and they have a lot of
information they want to share with you
um but it's just to discuss my role with
the committee so that you kind of
understand the purpose of what I'm here
to do and what to help get you through
um your charge is to come up with some
estimates on revenues specifically
unrestricted revenues of the general
fund fishing game fund and Highway fund
along with the general fund you will
address education trust
funds and I will help coordinate and put
together the materials that you need as
you go forward with this process so your
next two days You' have um agency
scheduled to talk with you um that was
at the direction of reps major and I
contact to the agencies and and let them
know what um they should be presenting
today um to get you
started I just wanted to kind of walk
you through the process as well um so
you're going to get lots of information
thrown at you you're going to hear about
a variety of different Revenue sources
and how the um agencies um are involved
in collecting that and and remitting
that back to the state
um one thing that I did do is put
together kind of a handbook or a
document and I'm just going to share my
screen I'm not going to go through the
whole document but there are some pieces
of it I wanted to share with
you so let me see
oh Brad could you turn on the screen
share it says it's disabled right
now so I'll just keep talking as as I
wait for that so you as you go through
your estimates you're going to be
revisiting fiscal year
21 figuring out um where you are in
terms of the year and where you might
end and then you're going to address 22
and 23 at the end of that process this
committee will put together a house
resolution of what your estimates
are
okay and that will go before
um the full body of the house and you
will discuss it and typically in the
past that document has been tabled so
let me just stop there for a minute so
you should Al just see a document with
uh LBA across the top the New Hampshire
quarter
that's we see it okay so
the right after that is a contact page
for our office because we're working
remotely the best way to contact me is
through email um but here are the
various people in our office Mike Kane
spoke with this committee last week um
Mike Hoffman Mickey landeron Nancy
lavenus and Kevin Ripple are all our
budget analysts who are um working
currently with house finance and putting
together information as it relates to
the operating budget my other charge is
not only house and ways and means but I
also work with the capital budget so
I'll be working with Public Works to put
that together as well but again that's
just our our information if you come
into or call our office you will
typically um you see Pam Ellis who's our
admin ministrative assistant she's kind
of the point person for us she's the
knower of all
information so the way this document is
structured is that um there's some
information on different acronyms or
terms you may hear throughout the
process followed by um just a quick
summary of the various tax rates for the
general and education trust trust fund
revenues that you are collected after
that is a resolution that was done for
fiscal year 2019 for your 21 uh excuse
me 2021 um operating budget and then
I'll show you um House Bill one or in
this case it was House Bill three the
operating budget and where your
estimates end up in
there understand that when you're doing
your estimates they will be done on
current law so as a committee of the
ways and means you will see bills coming
in that suggest or would want to make
changes to some of the revenue streams
that you're collecting um you wouldn't
consider that in your estimates that
would be something that would be
addressed um after when I say after that
would be incorporated into a surplus
statement that's prepared by our office
at the direction of um legislative
leadership um house finance and and the
ways and means chair um would direct our
office to put together that Surplus
statement and include certain
information
so again I just mentioned here's some of
the terms that you may see uh one thing
that people sometimes hear and confuse
is you'll hear the term road toll that
is not the the tolls that you see on the
turnpike system that is actually your
gas tax that you you'll hear about for
your Highway fund for unrestricted
revenues um but it's easy to get that
that mixed
up um as I said there's a page that just
kind of shows you the the rates so
across the top here you'll see the
business profits tax it's located in RSA
77a the rates are contained in Colon 2
the total rate for your business profit
tax right now is 7
.7% of that 1.5% goes to the education
trust fund and 6.2% goes to your general
fund that's directed by the statutes at
the end of this document are the the
statutes are listed along with some
historical
information this next document or piece
of document that I'm showing you
starting on page four is the house
resolution in 2019 for the operating
budget so once your committee was done
we put together this resolution that
shows you the education trust fund and
general fund um Revenue totals so you
had your official estimate for fiscal
year 19 and then what the committee
believed was going to happen with
revenues to the rest of
19 so that you can see the numbers are
slightly different than what had been
projected before and then from there you
built your estimates for 20 and
21 and you did the same thing for the
highway fund and the fishing game fund
so you're going to be seeing um
information historical information
coming to you from the agencies today
they're going to talk about the last
five years of their revenue collections
um you'll be able to see some Trends
with that there's information in this
document as well that you can look at um
I reference other documents within this
to direct you to as
well so once all your estimates are done
the resolutions pass
and your numbers are then included into
the house version of the operating
budget typically
that's House Bill one in this case it
three and you'll find
um in the budget you'll find your
operating budget your unrestricted
revenues in what they call the back of
the of the budget so as you can see here
this is Page 709 of the operating budget
all the information before that is the
the numbers you know the dollars that
have been appropriated to the
agencies everything after that or what
we refer to as the back of the budget or
sections in the back of the
budget and it has things like here this
is positions that have been abolished
from the budget because um these are
included in the operating budget these
position numbers if they an agency no
longer needs them or the legislature has
decided that they need to reduce some
positions they actually have to abolish
the
positions but then you will see here's
your unrestricted revenues these again
are just the estimates that you've made
based on current law these will be
adjusted through each phase of the
budget process so the house will have
its version the Senate would have its
version and then at Committee of
conference after um whatever Agreements
are made there would be a committee of
conference um ped version of the of the
um
revenues and as I stated there may be
some bills that get passed by the house
there may be bills that are passed by
the Senate and House and and look like
they're going to go into current law as
each phase goes we will in incorporate
those into the Surplus statement and
this document you see on your screen now
is is a um Surplus statement for the
current B any more in and again it you
address the year that you're building
the budget in so in this case you're
dealing with fiscal year 2019 and then
you have your fiscal 20 and 21 after
that on row four are your estimated
revenues so these are your truly the
numbers from House Bill one totaled up
this is education trust fund and general
fund together and then row five would be
any Revenue adjustments and those
Revenue adjustments would be again any
bills that would make changes to the um
revenues going forward that have been
passed or you believe will be passed or
any language that's contained in House
Bill 2 or the trailer bill Bill the
trailer Bill typically accompanies the
operating
budget and if I take you
to so this this page here page
15 um shows you schedule one which again
is all the the this is just the general
funds we break it up by General and
education trust funds so these are the
revenues that were contained in um House
Bill one or the operating budget and
then there's a page starts called
schedule two and you'll see there's a
whole bunch of activity on there and the
first top of that are Revenue
adjustments and why there's an
adjustment being made so line four for
instance in the operating budget they
added um some Dr auditor positions and
had some Revenue estimates associated
with adding those positions of $200,000
in fiscal year 20 and then two million
um in
2021 there was language that um dealt
with business tax Conformity there was
language related to the tobacco tax and
um applying the tax to ecigarettes and
there's different assumptions made on
what Revenue would be collected so
of we again we do the same thing for the
highway
fund scrolling slowly so I don't get
anybody too sick with the motion so we
do the same thing with the highway fund
as well as the fishing game fund so
there's a surplus statement that's
issued by our office to give you a sense
of what's occurring um typically we have
the four
columns Governor house senate and
Committee of conference on the earlier
for the general fund education trust
fund because the budget was vetoed and
there was a um negotiation that occurred
to
um get by that beeto and pass a budget
there was some changes that did occur in
three so once the budget's passed the
department of administrative Services
takes the Revenue information and builds
um a revenue a monthly Revenue
plan they do that with advice and and
discussions with the agencies that
collect the revenues and it's just to
get a sense of when you're going to see
revenues come into the state on a cash
basis and you you you'll hear as you go
through this process you know there
there's five months that are typically
your larger months for Revenue
collection September December which have
already occurred
and then March April and
June and you you will often hear that
the house is at a disadvantage with the
revenue projections because you haven't
seen March and April's
revenues um the past few bium the house
Ways and Means Committee has met in
April May and sometimes beginning of
June as you're going through this
process to revisit your revenues and you
may even do an amendment to the
resolution that you had tabled earlier
um part of that is just to make sure
that you have some um upto-date
information on what's going on with the
revenues so when you go to committee a
conference you can have that discussion
with the
Senate the revenue plan is put together
for the general fund the education trust
fund um fishing game and Highway
funds and again it's just a plan it's an
estimate you will sometimes see from one
month to the next that maybe a revenue
stream was below plan but it comes in
the following month
um so sometimes there's a timing issue
of of when things are
collected so you'll hear that discussed
and then what the department does after
that is at the end of each month they
put together the monthly Revenue focus
and you should start to receive
that um this is a good document to tell
you or get provide you some insight as
to what's occurring um with the
collection of your revenues this current
month is we'll show you um the
collection for the month of this is
December so in December your actuals
compared to plan and if you are below or
above that this analysis is just a brief
um commentary from the agencies on
what's happening with some of the major
taxes that are being collected um
sometimes it helps explain why a number
is up or down in a particular month and
what to expect maybe in the upcoming
month there's other information
contained in this document that relates
to real estate um transfer tax meals and
rooms um cigarette tobacco tax stamps um
there's also fishing game and Highway
fund at the end of this this table here
would show you just a comparison of uh
fiscal 21 to fiscal
20 and then again I think what is
probably more useful in this document is
this year-to-date comparison so this
provides you how much revenue have you
collected through
December and if you go down to the
bottom right hand corner you'll see that
you're 54.3 m milon do ahead of plan
after you've accounted for the $30
million of um that you've heard
mentioned that the
anomalous that came in 21 that should
have been credited to 20 and has been
done um in the cafer but because this is
on a cash basis it still shows up in the
numbers and so they just do a a
correction on this table and at the end
of the year they'll reverse that out
they in the department of administrative
services and then this table here just
shows you where the um revenue is
million and as I said you got the
highway and the fishing game fund also
on here so it's a it's a nice document
to look at you typically will see that
um three to five business days after the
close of the month um the department
usually will email that but it it's also
available on their website and there's
links on our website to
that this page here just gives you a
sense of for some of the revenue that's
collected and we'll use meals and rooms
as an example so in December when you
see the meals and rooms Revenue that is
for the activity that occurred in
November so just to kind of keep that in
mind when you're looking at some of
these that it's for the prior month's
activity that you're giving you're um
month and then this is a document that
our office puts together um at the end
of each month we will put all the data
into this spreadsheet and what it
provides you is over seven years um kind
of how much was collected in dollars on
a cash basis but then what percentage of
the year of collection that was so for
instance if you look at the business
profits tax you'll see that you know in
21 you collected $26 million but
typically you're somewhere
between 10 million and 17 million so
you're up in
21 so that may be something that you
consider as you think about your
estimating this is a 15-page document so
quick the cafer the comprehensive annual
financial report which has now been
released it was released um just prior
to December 31st um there's just a
couple of pages I wanted to point out in
there page eight is a surplus statement
so that would be the information that um
has been audited so those are the real
numbers those are the of of what
occurred in terms of revenues and any um
Appropriations that were were
expended and then also in that same
report on page 146 you have a historical
they provide a
10-year
um recap of the of the revenues that
have been collected there's other
information but I just point out the
revenues so in this case it's the
general funds and you can see that beer
taxes from 2011 has been ranging from $
12.9 million to a low of 12.6 in 2017 to
13.1 in 2020 so just gives you a sense
occurring I also show that for the
education trust
fund fishing game fund and the highway
fund so they're also in
there and I'm speeding up a little bit
because I I'm going to need to stop
because I want to let Di get
started um I also took a snippet from
the um offering statement from treasury
for the bonds and the reason that I
included this is there's some good
information as it relates to the revenue
stabilization Reserve account as well as
the various revenues that you're
collecting so starting on page there's
an it's called information uh statement
within the document on page 13 of that
is the revenue stabilization Reserve
account and following that are State
revenues and just gives you a little bit
of history on each of those just a
narrative um to read about if you're
trying to get a sense of what's going on
tax and then as I stated the last part
document contains the rsas as it relates
to the various Revenue sources that
you're looking at so here's the
education trust fund this RSA tells you
the various components that are
deposited into that here's the business
tax uh business profits
tax again RSA 77 A2 tells you what the
tax rate is and then in this case where
the funds are going is 77 a20 colon 20
so that's what I provide you in terms of
the rsas in this document and then I
follow that with these blue and gray um
charts these are actually charts that
come out of the dr's 2020 annual report
and that provides you a history of the
Inception of the tax all the way through
uh the most recent um completed year
which is
2020 so you can read all the changes
that have occurred and find a historical
context for that if if you choose to do
do so so again there's a lot of
information there you're going to hear
from the agencies you're going to get a
lot more information
um I just want you to know my role is to
assist you with any questions you might
have so as you look at things and you're
wondering um well I don't understand
where this tax you know came from or
who's paying for that you can reach out
to me if I can answer the question I
will if I can't I'll reach out to those
um individuals that could provide that
answer or connect you with those
individuals but I am here as a resource
to you um and and hope to be used in
that fashion so that that's all I have
now again I think we want to get Dr
started because they do have a lot of
information for you if there's any
questions I'm happy to take them but if
not well well thank you Chris that's it
was a great highlevel um review of of
what the LBA does to assist us in doing
our work in generating
revenues so next we want to go to the
Department of Revenue Administration and
we'll have on commissioner Lindy Lindsay
stepp assistant commissioner Carolyn
leer senior financial analyst Melissa
Rollins and financial analyst de
R you so uh commissioner you're on good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee thanks for having us today as
a reminder for the record Lindsay stepp
commissioner at the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue Administration I'm
going to take just a second to share my
presentation head nod perfect thank you
okay so good morning again as Mr chair
mentioned we have uh the full Dr Dream
Team here today I spoke to all of you
for quite a while last week so um I
decided to break things up today you'll
get to hear from all of us um as we move
through the presentation we're going to
go through each of the major taxes that
the Dr collects give you the background
on that um we will then um at the end
give some initial Revenue estimates for
fiscal year 21 and some ranges for 22
and 23 and last but not least I'm going
to give everyone an update on our new
Revenue information management system
Lindsay do you want to go through the
presentation first and then questions um
I think you know it worked really well
last week where we stopped at the end of
each tax and addressed any questions um
relevant to that tax type then so I
think we'll probably follow that same um
process if that works for you Mr chair
you okay so first just the mission of
the Department of Revenue um our mission
is to fairly and efficiently administer
the tax laws of the State of New
Hampshire collecting the proper amount
of taxes due incurring the least cost to
the taxpayers in a man manner that
merits the highest degree of public
confidence in our integrity further we
provide prompt and constructive
assistance to the municipal units of
government in matters of Budget Finance
and the appraisal of real
estate in terms of taxpayer interaction
it is the policy of the Department of
Revenue to administer the tax laws of
the State of New Hampshire in a manner
um that demonstrates efficiency fairness
and courtesy to every taxpayer and we do
take that our taxpayer
seriously
just to give you an overview of the
Department of Revenue this is a copy of
our organization chart you'll see all
the way on the left the administration
unit that is led by Carolyn leer
assistant commissioner and that's all of
your back office functions our business
office project management tax policy and
legislative analysis group who will be
presenting today legal internal audit HR
Etc we then have our audit division
which does exactly that they audit the
taxpayers in the state of New Hampshire
they're broken out into different groups
depending on the type of businesses so
we have the instate Bureau which um
audits businesses that are solely
contained in New Hampshire we have the
multi-state um Group which would uh
audit your very large multinational
corporations and then we have the multi-
entity Group which audits more of your
Regional businesses so like a regional
New England business or something like
that also with our multi- entity group
we have our tobacco group and that um
audits the tobacco tax uh to uh ensure
our compliance with um the tobacco tax
settlement agreement we also have a
discover Discovery Bureau within the
audit division which um seeks to find um
new or non-compliant taxpayers so
taxpayers that may not be aware of their
obligation here in New Hampshire and
then lastly our hearings management um
who handle the appeals that come through
the
department we have our collections
division which does our collections for
us so when all appeal rights have been
exhausted and um someone still owes
money to the department and to the state
they will be contacted by our
collections division we have our
Municipal and property Division and
those are the folks um that handle the
overseeing the appraisal of real estate
in the state of New Hampshire they also
in our Municipal unit set all the tax
rates um in the state as well as oversee
and provide guidance um for finance
related questions from the
municipalities we have our utility
proper group who assess utility property
in the state and then Timber and gravel
or Sticks and Stones they help the
municipalities administer the timber tax
and the gravel tax lastly all the way on
the right on our org chart is taxpayer
services so this is the division within
the department um that processes our
mail processes all of our Revenue um
they perform account maintenance they
man our call center so if you call into
the Dr you will talk to someone in
taxpayer services this is kind of a
One-Stop sh shop for any questions that
don't have to deal with an audit or
collections issue um you'll be sent to
Division I am going to potentially turn
it over to assistant commissioner
Carolyn Lear to talk through the next
few slides although um I might ask could
Carolyn leer Melissa Rollins and Devon
rodri all have the ability um to speak
Brad I'm not sure that they do at the
moment BR yes they should all have the
ability to speak
okay good morning
everyone uh Carolyn leer assistant
commissioner at the Department of
Revenue um good to all be with you today
um I'm going to talk about specifically
the tax policy and legislative analysis
Group which will be your primary contact
throughout the legislative session um
that's going to be me uh Melissa Rollins
who is a senior financial analyst with
the department and Devin rodri who is a
financial analysts with the Department
um last session you may have been
familiar with interacting with Sean
Thomas he has um left State service for
another opportunity so we will be the
three that you'll be communicating with
primarily along with commissioner step
and what we do throughout the
legislative session is we prepare fiscal
note worksheets and quick guides um for
legislation that comes before your
committee if you haven't seen them yet a
quick guide is a document that we're
going to be preparing for you um for any
legislation where we completed a fiscal
note it's our attempt to give you a uh
easily
digestible um understanding of the bill
and how we came up with our um fiscal
impact analysis and we certainly hope
you find those helpful um
will work with you in analyzing tax
policy and fiscal impact one of us or
more of us will attend um most if not
all of your hearings and be available
during work
sessions um and executive sessions to
answer any questions that you might have
I we'll occasionally testify uh before
you regarding tax policy and fiscal
impact we'll track legislation and then
at the end of the session um we'll set
forth with task of implementing all of
the tax law changes that you might pass
Lindsay um this slide is just a quick
tool um to let you know all of the taxes
that the department
administers um it lists the tax the
current rate as well as the statute that
implements the the tax and then below
you'll know there's a short list of the
taxes we don't administer um but often
do get inquiries about the insurance
premium tax which is administered by the
Department of Insurance although we do
get data about the IP um because it does
um act as a credit against business
taxes um the beer tax and then the road
toll which Chris talked about um is the
and then here is all of the taxes that
we
administer with the fiscal year 2020
audited Revenue um totaling
2.3 billion
dollar and the nfq met and railroad tax
are un audited cash um just to note
there but moving on to the next slide
think this is particularly an
interesting visual to help you visualize
um the proportion of Revenue that each
tax makes up so if you take a look at
for example the business profits tax
which is in sort of a dark blue and then
the bu business Enterprise tax in purple
you can see that business taxes are
greater than a quarter of all taxes that
the department administers um followed
up by the property tax and the meals and
rentals tax um All Above 10% of total
revenue and then some of the smaller
taxes um less than 10% so in this
presentation and in a lot of our
presentations before you um we'll spend
a lot of time talking about business
taxes and rightly so because it makes up
um a good proportion of the total taxes
collect
and now I think we're going to hand it
over to Melissa Rollins and Devin rodri
analysts good morning so we're going to
start with business profits tax this tax
is under RSA
77a it's
louder the tax is
77 % of taxal business profits for
periods ending December 31st hey Brad
volume I'm not able to if they're on
their computer you have to go into their
volume Melissa would help if you could
volume how about now can you hear me
now better could be
better okay let me start over for
business profits tax it's under RSA
77a it's 7.7% of taxable business
profits for tax period ending on or
after 1231
2019 so our current rate is the
7.7% who's taxable every Enterprise
Organization for gain or profit turning
on any business activity within the
state the threshold for the business
profits tax is gross business income in
excess of 50,000 from all
activities and then on the right where
when to file this is for calendar year
filers Chris chatted about this earlier
so partnership returns are due March 15
corporate prorip and fiduciary returns
are due April
15 and then there's also a 7-month
extension to file so this is an
extension to file and not pay so the
payment for these returns with the
extension is due by the return due date
which I stated
above and then lastly our estimate
payments so estimate payments for the
business profits tax are equal to 25% of
estimated tax liability and and are due
for a calendar year filers April 15th
June 15th so the first two payments are
due in the um the end of a fiscal year
and then September 15 and December 15th
for this third and fourth quarter
estimates and those estimate payments
are required if an estimate liability
exceeds
$200 moving on to the next
slide this information is pulled from
our triangles which is on the the
following slide but it's a really good
representation of our BP
taxpayers so for tax year
1.4% of filers paid 85% of
BPT and then the next two charts below
are showing who's filing and versus
who's paying so what's interesting about
this slide is on the left you'll see
that the largest amount of entities that
are filing business profits tax are
proprietorships at 41% however looking
on to the right they only make up 3% of
what is paid for
BPT and then to switch back over to
who's filing 6% of Water's Edge or
combined
filers are filing the tax but they
represent 62% of what is being paid
tax and then on the next slide this is
the the triangles representative major
you allude to these a bit these are
located in our annual report this is who
pays the business profits tax um and on
the top you'll see sort of that inverted
triangle and that breaks out tax
reported on the business profits tax and
then it has c c files the amount that
they pay and then it's um some
percentages based on that and what's
interesting with the business profits
tax if you look at that lower smaller
portion of the triangle around 600
filers pay almost 80% of the business
profits St so just an interesting slide
paying and then this slide is the BBT
revenue and the 10-year
Trend this is audited Revenue so when we
refer to audited Revenue that's coming
out of the Capper Chris talked about the
comprehensive annual report um on here
we have the 10-year Trend in the blue
and then we have fiscal year 21 plan
with a dotted green line on the right we
also give you a historical view of the
bbp tax rates over the
years what's important to know on
business profits tax is some factors
that influence the revenue this is
located at the bottom of the slide the
economy federal tax reform mergers and
acquisitions
credits and exemptions and then
statutory
changes so for instance the business tax
rate reduction the trigger was not met
7.7% and then we also have Market based
sourcing in effect for tax will periods
ending on or after December 31st
2021 as well as single sales Factor
apportionment for tax will periods
ending on or after December 31st
2022 so give a little bit more
information about market-based
sourcing so for business profits when
they are reported prior to being taxed
they're a portion so portion portion is
split into two pieces so we have
intangible sales and services so we
switched from cost of performance where
those intangible sales and services were
portioned based on where Services were
perform
and we switched now to Market based
sourcing and that's where those tangible
excuse me those intangible sales and
services are now portioned to where the
End customer is located so that's the
first change that just went into effect
and then the second change that will be
going into effect for taxable periods
ending on or after December 31st 2022 is
for tangible items So currently we use a
three Factor apportionment meaning sales
property and payroll with sale with
sales being devil weighted are how the
tangible items are a portioned and when
we switch to single sales factor that
means only sales will be factored in and
a portioned and will no longer include
payroll in
property and I think that's it for
business profits tax before we move on
to business Enterprise tax so I'm happy
to answer any questions
here
uh let me
see Brad I want to pull up the
participant
list you just need to click the um
participants button at the bottom of the
screen I'm going to the bottom of the
screen
I share okay here we
go
out okay if anybody has any questions if
they would raise their hands and if they
screen and I don't see any questions at
Perfect all right business business
Enterprise tax this is the second tax
that makes up our total business taxes
the business Enterprise tax is under RSA
77p the current tax rate is
0.6% of the Enterprise Value tax base
for tax will periods ending on or after
December 31st
2019 when we say Enterprise Value tax
base that consists of compensation wages
paid or approved as well as interest
paid or approved who PID this tax every
profit or nonprofit Enterprise or
organization with any business activity
inside New Hampshire except 501c3
organizations the thresholds on the
business Enterprise tax are a little bit
different than the business profits tax
as they are adjusted by CPI every two
years so currently for tax bill periods
ending January 1
2021 gross business receipts in excess
of
220,000 or Enterprise Value tax base
greater than
111,000 so the business Enterprise tax
has two different thresholds um and
either or need to be
met also important to note is the credit
for business Enterprise tax against
there's a credit for the business
Enterprise tax against the business
profits tax due so if you pay the
business Enterprise tax and also have a
liability on the business profits tax
you deduct what you paid for business
of in this tax is also carry forward any
unused credit for 10 years and then when
to file or pay the business profits tax
and the business Enterprise tax come in
on the same return with a sort of a
cover sheet that's called the BT summary
and so the due dates for the Enterprise
tax mirror the due dates for the
business profits tax with the exception
of nonprofits who are not required to
fire the business profits tax those are
15 all right this slide should look
familiar to you except it's for the
business Enterprise tax and it's
slightly different you'll see that 3.9%
of filers pay
73.9% of that so it's spread out a
little bit more however some of the
trends are the same again proprietor
ships are filing more yet they're paying
only 7% of the tax and again wat's Edge
are filing 6% but they're paying 53% of
tax going on to the next so the
triangles again this is in our annual
report um pretty similar except I'm
looking at that bottom of the triangle
again and 268 taxpayers pay 43% of the
tax so not quite as drastic as the
tax moving on and here is the business
Enterprise Revenue 10-year Trend again
you can see some dips and some spikes um
factors influen the business Enterprise
tax are the economic cycle including
employment levels and wages which makes
sense because it's taxed on wages and
compensation federal tax reform credits
and exemptions and then any statutory
changes which for the business
Enterprise tax was the business tax rate
which again the trigger was not met and
then the adjustment of the thresholds
years and then here is a combined slide
so again we typically report the BET and
BPT together um it just makes sense
because they kind of go hand inand and
they flow together on one return so this
just shows the trend with them together
as well as the fiscal year 21 plan and
again you can see some Peaks which are
and some of those areas are due to some
mergers and Acquisitions and some
anomalous payments and then we sort of
dip down some 16 you see it Peaks up
because of those situations that I just
stated it drops back down in 17 which
would sort of have been the trend if it
continued and then in 18 and 19 You See
It Peak back up and that's due to some
federal tax reform and then it's dropped
slide so this is just an interesting
slide to keep handy um I know there's a
lot of information on it but what we
really wanted to show on this slide is
how calendar year filers compared to
State fiscal year filers because it can
get a little bit confusing when
listening to our fiscal notes and the
fiscal impact because they don't
necessarily align so in the top chart
you can see on the left hand side that
2019 returns that were due fall outside
of fiscal year 21 and then when you
shift to to the right hand side on this
top box for calend year filers you'll
see that third quarter estimate payments
as well as 2019 Returns on extension in
the fourth quarter estimate payments
fall within the first half of fiscal
year 21 so essentially what it shows is
that tax years overlap fiscal years so
in a fiscal year you have mult multiple
tax years flowing into one fiscal year
and you can see that on the bottom that
fiscal year
2021 is made up of 2019 as well as 2020
returns and the um 2021 estimate
payments so when we're when they're
implementing tax laws those tax laws May
and are typically for calendar years but
they do impact multiple fiscal years so
just a good chart to have handy when
we're talking about calendar year and
fiscal
slide and I'm going to go through the
next couple of slides fairly quickly
because you're you should be familiar
with them because Lindsay had talked
about them in the previous um
presentation so this one again is just
showing the impact of our diff different
payment type so we have tax return
payments estimate payments extension
payments and then tax notice payment and
refunds and I think what's important to
note on this slide is that estimates
make up the bulk of the payments that
are coming in and it shows a good trend
of of how those payments flow in and how
they contract andand for
decrease the next slide this just breaks
down business tax estimates uh just
shows the entities that pay the
estimates um and the bulk of estimates
that come in the bulk of the revenue is
from corporations and then Partnerships
proprietorships with a small amount
slide all right I think that's it for
business taxes are there any questions
if not we can move to meals and rooms
tax I question nor Miss Pat I for some
reason I have a question please I know
my hand I my my my raised hand icon
doesn't work mine doesn't either it's
true for me too oh okay we were trying
Brad
Brad because what'll happen everybody
wants to talk at once
and representative major U I was on the
other line um why is it that raise hand
work
okay should um who's trying to raise
their hand um representative Ronney is
them was Ames and Tucker as well that I
heard it should be at the bottom of
their screen or it could be at the
bottom of the participants list I know
because someone sharing their screen
need to go up to view options and then
select um exit full screen oh wait a
minute view
option excuse me it doesn't seem to be
on the screen at all there's just invite
me well they have a raised hand it just
doesn't work yeah because it's in full
screen you need to select view options
at the top of the screen and then and
then select exit full screen and it will
up here at the bottom of your screen the
responding maybe we can just hold up our
hands while I figure this for some
reason it worked for me but I'm a
co-host so po represent Galo do you can
you help us out on this I I don't know
any I I know it's working for me as you
can see but what I'm find not to
interrupt but what I'm finding is if you
go to the participants click on that
click on the
panelists and then you'll have the
option that's the only way I'm getting
responding
hello I just shot a email to Lindsay I
mean a text to L not Lindsay um excuse
for okay I raised my hand but it it's
not
showing and I don't want to raise my
hand yeah because it's a disaster we
can't have dysfunction
working because we don't see
any have the screen shared you don't see
participants
um Mr Cher I'll stop sharing my screen
okay still not working on my
end
P the same
[Music]
problem allow attendees to raise hand
checked
hand guess if we're in if we're in this
mode we can just raise our hands like
this Norm just and you can pick them
right I only see you and about four
others you got to go to full screen you
gallery I think they at least come up to
the top of the list if you want to look
at the four that are at the top maybe
okay why don't we do
list is representative
Tucker so representative Tucker thank
you I have a question about the slide
that talks about the floor that's
established for the business Enterprise
tax and uh does that change very
often has it changed very often the
amount yes great question representative
Tucker can you guys hear me better now
oh yes all right I I was able to make
some changes while you had some
discussion so thank you um so yeah so it
changes every two years and since it's
been in place it has increased every two
years so I think for the last six years
or so um it's adjusted so it's every two
so I think it's adjusted three times
since being implemented so do you is it
fairly
incremental or a
percentage y so it's it's based on a lot
of time as a group talking about who
ought to be Exempted or who should have
things lowered but I hadn't really real
thought about that floor and how that
probably helps Mom and Pops Enterprises
and so forth so that's why I'm asking is
it uh sort of an automatic incremental
change or is it thoughtful to direct
itself to a
problem um I think it's s thoughtful
it's directed by the statute so there's
a formula within the statute that
requires Dr to adjust it based on CPI
the average increase of CPI over the
last completed um calendar year so it's
it's based on the growth obviously in
the economy so that I think it's a
thoughtful um statute that's put in
there and it's it's very descriptive in
telling Dr how to calculate the increase
repres representative bronley followed
by represen S yeah mine's more of a
comment we when we were talking about
BPP when we were talking about Market
based sourcing and single sales Factor
there's I'm introducing a bill on
Thursday that we actually worked through
last year um on on both those issues
it's a very important issue it'll be the
last bill of of the day on Thursday and
I think Dr will will also be there to be
part of this discussion thank you then
representative
gor I do not have any yeah I don't have
a question okay the next one would be
representative
Ames thank you um yeah this is a
question about the division of revenues
between bet and
BBT and I wonder if you could run
through exactly how
you allocate the revenues between those
two taxes at what point can we know that
it's uh it's a final
allocation what points is it an estimate
how do you how do you do
it great question representative Ames so
the I'm going to explain how we were
historic Al doing it and then we've made
some changes recently so historically
the way the business Enterprise tax and
business profits tax is split is on we
do it on a monthly basis but it's not
based on the actual split that we are
familiar with with what the taxpayer
will be filing it's based on historical
numbers so for example when we're
getting estimate payments flowing into
the department on the
form it's split between bet and PPT
however most taxpayers just put the
total business tax that they're paying
they don't necessarily split it out
between the two taxes because as I
stated before the Returns come in on one
form One summary form with the two taxes
below so most taxpayers view it as one
tax when they're paying their Enterprise
Value tax and their business profits
tax however we need to split this
between business profits tax and
business Enterprise tax because Chris
spoke to it does get split separately
between the general fund and education
trust fund so typically this is done
based on the last completed fiscal year
or two years prior to the last completed
fiscal year so as of July 1st every year
the department sets the business profits
tax and Inter business Enterprise tax
split based on two prior fiscal
years so the split is then performed at
the end of every month to fully split
out those taxes so we always recommend
don't look at the BET and BPT amounts
throughout the month because they're
just flowing in and they're they're sort
of offset but when you get to the end of
the month we do a transfer to put the
funds into the appropriate count based
on that historical
split okay representative
Bernstein wait I don't think she's
finished yeah so I just wanted to add
one more piece so now because of the
implementation of rims so starting in
October we've been able to do a little
bit better job on that split so the
payments that come in that are
not split between bet and P BPT are
still based on historical amounts
however if they do come in with a split
we put them into the appropriate account
and then when you come in March and
April and those returns are filed those
returns will chew up those estimates
that were based on historic split to be
the actual split so I think coming this
March and April it's the first time that
we're going to have true accurate splits
between bet and
BBT um based on the most recent data
received hopefully that makes sense it's
a lot to kind of throw out there thank
you you're welcome representative
Bernstein I I do not have a question
right now okay um repr Aly did you have
a question yes I was trying to figure
out since I'm at the top I don't know
how whether I've managed to to ask or
not but um I'm I want to go back to what
representative Tucker was asking about
because uh you and I were actually there
at the time it was during the O'Brien
Administration and on there was a bill
that came in to say that on the amount
of the floor should be doubled for the
BET and I thought that was awful and I
went and analyzed it and in fact the in
order to reach the same level after
inflation we did need to double it but
that was kind of a shock to the system
so I asked that we put in the CPI
indicator so that it would rise
gradually rather than all at once and uh
they we did that all of us
but and so that's that's why that's in
there and it's kind of I think important
in tax policy the problem of floors
thank you okay is there any others that
question s then we can
rs good morning chairman members of the
committee this is Devon rodri Financial
analy of the Department of Revenue can
everyone hear me okay uh yes yes great
so the meals and rentals tax is a 9% tax
on meals rooms and motor vehicle rentals
it is paid by the consumer and collected
and remitted by operators of hotels
restaurants in motor vehicle rental
establishments etc for operators meeting
certain criteria like filing returns
timely and paying on time they are
allowed to retain a commission of
3% return returns are filed monthly for
M&R and are due by the 15th of each
following month as Chris Shay mentioned
earlier during December we received
returns and payments for activity that
occurred in
November operators are able to file
electronically using Grant tax connect
our online taxpayer portal which went
live in October 2019 and Lindsay will go
later a paper return is not required if
um sorry one
second so the the gross meals and
rentals tax liability reported by
activity type so from on average from
fiscal year 2016 to fiscal year 2020
historically M&R Revenue consists of 80%
meals 177% rooms and 3% motor vehicle
this has been pretty consistent over
time on the following slide we'll look
at this breakdown by county for fiscal
year
2020 the top portion of this slide shows
how much M&R tax liability was reported
in each County as well as how much each
County represents of all REM M&R Revenue
collected Statewide the chart is
organized left to right based on how
much was reported in fiscal year
2020 it's important to note at this
point as it relates to the data on this
slide that the Dr does not collect
information on exactly where M&R tax
revenue is generated rather the data in
these charts represents the revenue
collected based on the address of the
operator the reporting location is often
different than the location where the
taxable transaction occurred in where
M&R tax was actually collected many M&R
operators for example file their Returns
on a Consolidated basis meaning the
operator reports am our tax collected
from several business locations on a
single return another example might be
mobile businesses who may be collecting
tax throughout the throughout the state
on different different counties
the lower portion of this slide answers
a question from the last presentation by
representative Tucker who was interested
in the breakdown by County remember from
the previous Slide the Statewide
breakdown is on average is 80% meal 177%
rooms and 3% motor
vehicle this chart is organized you can
see in the blue column from left to
right Which counties have a higher
percentage of meals
activity you'll notice that the counties
to the far right the first of three of
which are from the north country have a
much higher percentage of rooms than the
Statewide average for example Coos
County being 47% of rooms versus a
Statewide average of just
17% and likewise all the way to the left
straford county has only %. this really
speaks to the differences in the types
state the next
slide this is the familiar 10year trend
of audited Revenue per the caffer um
you'll see the the trend for the past 10
years in the blue line and you'll notice
the dip in FY
2020 factors influenced M&R tax include
covid-19 as can be seen in the chart
above um when the econom is thriving M&R
tax revenue is usually increasing
unemployment rates also affect this tax
by weighing down consumer spending the
weather also plays a factor and
correlates with travel and tourism which
was obviously affected during the last
year generally favorable weather
conditions during the summer and winter
can positively affect M&R as well as
strong foliage
seasons are there any questions on the
M&R tax at this
questions we'll try this participant
list
again I don't see any hands raised but
um if you do have a question just Pi up
and see if we can do it pat um just a
clarifying thing for the new members
just to make sure when they say 3% goes
to the uh organization col collecting
the revenue that's 3% of what's
collected not 3% of the 9% sometimes it
could be a little confusing but it's
confused and that total amount for
fiscal year 2020 was 9 million across
State this is on Sue I guess we're on
first name at the moment uh on the the
3% is meant to compensate for the
administrative costs of collecting our
tax and sending it in and they're much
higher than that I think for the
smallest Enterprises and lower than that
for the chains
cost and the in the past there's been
legislation to eliminate this to raise
our Revenue but it's never gotten
anywhere and I I think it works okay the
way it
is and no other questions and we can
tax
uh who's speaking on the tobacco tax I
think it's Melissa Melissa are you
taking I yes I was on mute I
apologize all right tobacco tax this is
under RSA
78 this one is made up of a couple
different components so for one portion
of the tax it's based on stamp so it's a
$1.78 per pack of 20 cigarettes or
$223 per pack of 25 cigarettes and then
the other portion of the tobacco tax is
the other tobacco products or OTP as we
refer to them and those are 65.0 3% of
the wholesale sales price for all other
tobacco products except ecigarettes
for ecigarettes I believe Lindsay
covered this in the the last
presentation ecigarette tax went into
effect on January 1st of last year it's
levied on both the closed system and
open system and is reported on the OTP
return the closed system tax is a rate
of
0.3 Z per aill liter on the volume of
the liquid of other substance containing
nicotine in the cartridge or container
and the other in the open system is 8%
of the wholesale price of the container
of liquid or other substance so again
it's the 30 cents per milliliter on um
for the closed systems and then 8% on
the wholesale price of the container of
liquid for the open systems it's
important to note premium cigars are
exempt from the tobacco tax the tax on
tobacco products is a direct tax upon
the consumer at retail but it's prepaid
or excuse me pre-collected and paid by
the
wholesaler for packs of 20 or 25
cigarettes payment of the tax is
evidenced by the wholesaler's purchase
of tobacco tax stamps which are fixed to
each package so essentially the
wholesaler comes to the department buys
the stamps for the cigarettes they pay
the tax at that point they put the stamp
on the package of the cigarettes those
are then sold to the
retailers and who are then passed on the
consumer and the consumer is paying it
within the price however it's initially
paid by the
wholesaler so for cigarette sold in in
packages or quantities other than than
20 or 25 not suitable for stamping and
for OTP the other tobacco products which
is essentially loose tobacco or chewing
tobacco um the wholesaler must be
reported and and pay the tax liability
on the monthly basis this is paid
similar to the M&R tax the return and
payment of the tax are due honor before
the 15th day of the month following the
end of the reporting period and then
just the last piece of this that is
important to note because it's in our
reports as well
stamps may be purchased on a bond filed
with the department so meaning these
wholesalers receive a bond they purchase
their stamp on Bond and then they have
30 days to pay that Bond off so some of
the tobacco stamps are paid with cash
and others are paid on bond which is
received 30 days
later uh next
slide so for tobacco tax for fiscal year
16 to fiscal year 20 on average tobacco
tax Revenue were composed primarily of
cigarette stamps sales so that's 94% of
the revenue is coming from cigarettes
and then 6% is coming from OTP and
you'll see on future slides that the OTP
portion of the tobacco tax although
small has continued to grow um pretty
regularly over each
year in this breakdown again um you had
seen in Prior presentations but we
wanted to sort of put it all into one
place this is the tobacco stamp Revenue
what it looks like and you can see that
the Peaks and Valley sort of cor
correspond with the rate increase and
decrease that are to the
left and then
OTP this is a chart that you've seen
before but again as I spoke to you can
see that the percentage or the dollars
of OTP have pretty consistently gained
year over-year with fiscal year 20 being
the highest so far and the rates are on
well so for tobacco tax revenue this is
the 10-year Trend you can see that it's
kind of increased and decreased we show
some rates to help follow those
increases and decreases over the year
you can see that fiscal year 21 plan um
is close to what fiscal year 19 audited
Revenue ended at and you can see fiscal
year 20 um has been performing Pretty
well as well as that trend is continuing
through fiscal year
21 factors that influence that revenue
is crossborder elasticity ecigarettes
stamp sales Trend as well as again
Lindsay spoke about this in the last
presentation presentation the
Massachusetts band on mental products
that went into effect June 1st 2020 um
we've seen a pretty big gain in fiscal
year
change so this is a newer slide but we
found it to be interesting based on some
of the questions that the
representatives had during the um
economic briefing presentation what this
shows on the left is tobacco tax rates
by state so this has the tax rate per a
pack um so New Hampshire's a178
highlighted in blue and we rank 26th for
the um highest level or lowest level
however you want to say it for tax rates
and then these are our nearby States and
you can see they increase pretty dramat
dramatically from Maine being the
closest to us at $2 per a pack with New
York being the highest at 435 per pack
so this does show that there is a
pretty a pretty good um range between
what we have assessed versus what our
our local New England states have
assessed and then on the right
um just some more interesting
facts the the ranking of smuggled
cigarettes consumed as a percentage of
total cigarettes consumed in 20 2018
both of these informations are not Dr
informations I should have stated that
in the beginning um this is from tax
Foundation we have the lowest rate of
smuggle cigarettes consumed as a
percentage of total consumed within the
state so we rank 47 so way down of the
amount of smuggled cigarettes into New
Hampshire that are consumed um sort of
the inverse of this is we have we are
one of the highest um states that are
rate and I think that is it for the
tobacco tax slide so happy to answer any
questions okay any questions on the
tobacco
tax
um rent major could I ask uh
about this slide itself does that tax
rate include the sales tax which I think
all of them put on top no great question
representative alme I should have stated
that this does not so this is just the
straight tax rate and does not include
the sales tax that is also assessed by
catch so m i I think as what about 6%
tax yeah making that even a larger range
hours all right uh anything any other
questions to spake up we'll try
that yeah just comment that M um
advertisers in Massachusetts are now uh
congratulating that's representing yly
go ahead representing y I'm sorry
getting used to this again you may have
noticed that um um tobacco shop
operators uh further south in
Massachusetts are advertising and
they're including a thanks to the uh
legislature in Massachusetts for sending
Hampshire
yes any further questions or
comments seeing none we can move on to
real estate transfer tax
the real estate the real estate transfer
tax or R is a tax on the sale granting
and transfer of real property or
interest in Real Property it is imposed
at a rate of 75 cents per $100 of the
price or consideration for sale granting
or transfer on both the buyer and the
seller on each
transaction red is paid by buying stamps
which are fixed to the deed from the
register of deeds in the county where
the property is
located um each Register of Deeds remits
the taxes collected to the Dr on a
monthly basis and it retains 4% of the
face value of the stamp sold in the
county in real estate holding company
transactions the taxes remitted directly
slide this chart shows the average
percentage of transactions and
percentage of overall tax collected Per
County in fiscal year
2020 it's interesting to note the trends
are not always the same for instance
Grafton County had 14.4% of the
transactions but only represented about
6.4% of the
revenue conversely at the same time
Rockingham County had
19.8% of the number of
transactions and represented 28.7% of
the revenue collected
Statewide so this is here for your
slide here you'll see the familiar
10-year audited Revenue Trend per the
caffer the current um r tax rate like I
explained a minute ago in total $150 per
100 um dollars the price of
consideration of transfer which includes
both the purchaser and the seller that
was in effect throughout this time frame
so you can see the r tax has been
gradually increasing over the last 10
years it is influenced by Eon economic
Trends including mortgage interest rates
which are currently at historically low
levels property values obviously heavily
influence R Revenue as we've seen over
the last
year a couple figures from the New
Hampshire realtors association the
median sales price in December 2020 was
up 16.6% for single family homes from
the previous December and uh Townhouse
Condo properties are up 23 a. half% from
a year ago available inventory of real
estate for sale also influences this tax
again as of December inventory had
decreased 62% for single family homes
and 47% for Townhouse Condo properties
from a year
prior lastly over the last year there's
been a continued shift in demographics
from Urban to more rural areas as many
people being to shift away from the more
um heavily populated densities which
will help increase net migration in
Hampshire uh presumably have a positive
influence on the real estate transfer
tax we've seen that over the last
year are there any questions on the real
estate transfer
tax okay
up don't see hear anybody so we'll go on
to interest and dividend
tax all right interest and dividends tax
this is under RSA 77 it's a 5% tax on
interest in dividend dividends income
who pays it is all New Hampshire
residents fiduciaries llc's Partnerships
and associations with income from
interest in dividends the threshold for
this tax is 20 400 annually or if you
file jointly it's 4,800 there's also an
exemption with this tax of 1,200 for
residents age 65 or older blind or
disabled before their 65th
birthday this this tax is due on April
15th this tax also has a seven-month
extension similar to the business
profits and business Enterprise tax
which is due April 15th with the return
being due 7 months
later and and it also has estimate
requirements so the estimates equal to
25% of estimated tax liability the due
dates are April 15th June 15th September
15th which those fall in line with the
business taxes however the fourth
quarter estimate payment for interest in
dividends tax is due January 15th of the
subsequent year so this month is an indd
estimate tax month for their fourth
quarter estimate payment and they're
only required to make estimates if their
$500 so again we have some pictures of
how IND taxpayers file for tax year
2018 on the left we have entities paying
98.3% of the filers for interest in
dividends tax are individuals and Joint
filers with the remaining
1.7% for Partnerships in Estates and
then we have a little comment below
where the entities that are uh filing
the tax the above is paying um is pretty
similar with
97 point actually it's basically the
same 97.3 and then 2. 66 for
Partnerships in estimates what's
interesting on this slide on the right
is interest in dividends tax broken down
by the areas of what is taxed so
although it's called interest in
dividends tax there are a few other
items that make up this tax with
interest being
133% of the tax dividends being 40% of
the taxed federal tax exempt interest is
7.7% or 8% of the tax and then there's
distributions and distributions about
39% of the tax this does shift over the
years um and especially I think you
would you would note that interest does
increase or decrease based on what the
interest rate is
at on the next slide we have the
triangles again that are from our annual
report not as exciting as the business
profits tax and business Enterprise tax
triangles you'll see in the middle here
um 40% of the tax is paid by about
23% of the people filing so this tax is
split out a little bit more evenly than
the business profit and business
Enterprise
tax on the next slide we have interest
and dividends tax revenue for the
10-year Trend you'll see over the prior
earlier years on this tax there's some
peaks in valleys and then for the last
four or five years it's consistently
increased some factors that can that
influence this revenue is obviously the
economy stock market performance
interest rates federal tax reform or
people who have money in the
bank happy to answer any questions on
the indd
tax okay any questions on the indd
tax since we the raiseed hand function
isn't working um let's try just picking
up and it's representative Aly
again I I must admit I don't really
understand what a distribution
is can you clarify by that I don't think
we looked at this until a few years
ago sure so distributions um an example
of a distribution would be a
distribution from maybe an LLC or a
partnership or an association would be
subject to the tax so if they pay that
distribution out to a corporate
shareholder um it would be tax as a
dividend but if they are paying it out
um to an individual it's a distri bution
so it's split a little bit differently
dividend Caroline or lindsy you can feel
clarification okay uh anything else on
questions s not we can go over to the
communication Services
tax the communication services tax or
CST is a 7% tax on all two-way
communication Services it's paid by the
consumer and collected by two-way
Communication service providers who are
required to collect and tax collect the
tax and file a return those returns are
due on the 15th day of the following
month however estimate payments are
required during each month if the tax
slide here's the 10-year Trend again of
audited Revenue it's important to note
that in 2012 chapter 279 added
definitions of internet and internet
access and excluded them from the
definition of communication
Services also over time there's a
decrease in landlines which has
contributed to a decrease in the revenue
as well as modern pricing and purchasing
trends for w Wireless
Communications and lastly hb4 of 2019
clarified that retailers a pre paid
Wireless and VOIP must assess and
CST there any questions about
CST questions on communication Services
tax have to speak up
again representative elme again could
you tell us whether you're having
success in getting the VoIP and video
pay good question
I'm gonna refer to Lindsay and
Carolyn I'll jump in there I think I
mentioned last week that we were looking
into that um and we will be doing some
auditing and some proactive Outreach
obviously it's only been a few days
since that time so that process is still
underway thank you sorry no worri just a
followup on that
has have you uh interfaced at all with a
zoom organization
ation um I can't talk about any
interactions with specific taxpayers
unfortunately given um our
confidentiality statutes but obviously
the zoom platform is a very well-known
um video conferencing platform so um
they we are aware of the uh
functionality that they
provide okay followup question on that
is how about any platform that performs
this have you interfaced with
so obviously there are multiple
platforms um Zoom the state uses
Microsoft teams we've also used utilized
the WebEx platform um and so again those
are all um taxpayers or businesses that
um we would be looking to in terms of um
determining whether or not they owe
communication services do you know do
you know if any other states have
collected from them I'm not aware
specifically of any other state it would
depend on their specific um tax uh
policies and if they had an equivalent
communication Services tax I'm not I'm
not sure if other states have a similar
tax okay so we have some work to do we
do and I mentioned that last week that
you know this is something that we are
aware of and that we are looking
into all right any for questions or
comments on the communication Services
tax see hearing none we can go to the
Medicaid enhancement
tax all right Medicaid enhancement tax
otherwise known as met this is under RSA
84A this tax is a little bit different
as it is a restricted Revenue source so
this isn't a tax that you estimate
revenues on um but we do administer it
so we want to cover it so the Medicaid
enhancement tax is 5.4% tax upon net
Patient Service revenue of Hospital it's
paid by General hospitals that provide
inpatient and outpatient hospital
services and not including government
facil
facilities the way this is taxed and the
reporting period is a little bit
different than our other periods the tax
period for mat is a 12-month period
running on a fiscal year July 1st ending
June 30th and the tax due is based on
the hospital's fiscal year ending during
the calendar year in which the tax bill
period begin so just as an example right
now we
in the Met tax will period ending June
30th 2021 and that will be reported for
hospitals period end dates that ended in
2020 so how met is filed and paid one
difference with met is that each
Hospital must file a nonbinding estimate
honored before January 15th and this is
a projected tax payment so it's just an
informational estimate payment that
tells us what they anticipate their tax
to be due when the return is due in
April 15th so in April 15th they file
return on the next
slide we have a picture of met
historical revenue or their historical
Trends and this is cash basis net of
refunds so you can see that it has
gradually increased and uh fiscal year
20 is fiscal year 21 plan is close to
fiscal year 20 ual revenue and Below we
have some of the rates over the previous
years and then lastly factors that
influence revenue is obviously Hospital
service utilization the more people in
the hospital the more tax that is is
paid and then the last slide that we
have for met is just to give you our
role in The Met administration because
it's a little bit different where it's a
dual role between Dr and DHHS so the
hospitals file the non-binding estimate
with us on January 15th so we just
received most of those estimates they
filed that with the Dr and then once we
have all the estimates in we notify uh
DHHS of the estimated payments we also
notify house Ways and Means and Senate
Ways and Means so you'll be getting a
letter on that here in the next coming
week or
so um 100% of the Met owed is due to the
Dr honor before April 15 so we received
those return we received those returns
and those payments and then we deposit
those funds into the uncompensated care
and Medicaid fund established by RSA 167
col 64 again that's into a restricted
revenue
account lastly the commissioner of DHHS
is responsible for expending those funds
in accordance with RSA 167 colon 64 and
this is for what you'll hear as termed
the Dish payment so it's a dish
proportionate share Hospital pay payment
and other medicated expenditures so just
at a very high level the Met money Flows
In from the hospitals the hospitals
report that they get or the excuse me
let me start over the money Flows In
from the
hospitals we report that to DHHS we get
some matching funds from the federal
government and then the hospitals get
some of that money back in what's termed
a Dish
payment lastly Dr is authorized to audit
met returns and we can also collect
unpaid
met happy to answer any questions in any
questions on Medicaid
enhan this is representative Ames y yes
representative Ames okay um yeah when I
first came into Ways and Means eight or
nine years nine years ago we were uh
actively uh reviewing the Met um and
estimating um revenues from it that
changed it became a restricted fund I
understand that but what I don't
understand is why Ways and Means is
not uh
estimating going forward on what is in
fact a very large Revenue
stream and I'm not sure anyone else is
doing that other than the hospitals am I
right about that
maybe um there are others who answer
this
question better but I I'll just throw it
out
there I think cret might be able to
answer
that Chris yep um I can try so typically
the role excuse me the role of the
committee has been to deal with just the
unrestricted Revenue estimates you have
many many many restricted revenues in
the state um that you don't address
directly the legislature through RSA has
given authority to an entity to collect
and distribute the revenue unlike the
general fund unrestricted Revenue which
doesn't get appropriated until you build
the budget so I I think there maybe some
distinction with you've already provided
some authority to entities to spend
money that's been collected so you don't
need to do the estimates they're Bound
by um rules and laws that say your
estimates need to meet your expenses if
your expenses exceed any Revenue then
you need to reduce your um basically
your appropriation for that restricted
Revenue in the terms of um the met that
was three or three or four budgets ago
that was change from a general fund
unrestricted Revenue to a restricted
Revenue within
HHS and as Melissa described it's used
for the the dish or just proportionate
share to hospitals where um basically
they make up for some of the
uncompensated care that they um have
provided and then if there's anything
left the department is able to use that
towards provider payments after they've
taken care of the the dish aspect um but
yeah that's the best answer I have for
you representative Ames is that um
typically the those restricted funds
have uh the ability and statute to be
expended collected and expended already
whereas the unrestricted Dome that's
taken care of through your operating
budget and passing that piece of
legislation
and and Chris how
many what is the approximate number of
unrestricted funds there I mean
restricted funds are there out there so
your your dedicated funds you have in
excess of there's been over 350
dedicated funds created over the years
not all of those still exist some of
those are repealed um over the years
they don't reuse the same
number but you have dedicated funds or
restricted funds in almost every agency
um for one reason or another um the has
agreed that um a particular Revenue
stream should be dedicated for a certain
purpose and has provided that in the
statute restricted funds are not um
funds that agencies just decide to keep
and and do what they want with there's
there's Direction provided in statute
for them to use that money but yeah so
there's probably somewhere over 300 that
are active or are still in existence I
should say because not all dedicated
funds are necessarily active they're
just may be sitting there dormant um and
your committee Ways and Means Committee
does look at that um periodically you
look at the dedicated funds and and make
determinations on what should happen
with those right there's a separate
committee it's a joint committee to look
at that every year to see which ones are
active or inactive which ones should be
done away with and our committee will be
handling legislation this year as a
result of
committee and Norm It's Pat Norm yes can
I speak up um yeah I've consulted in
hospitals for 43 years so I know a
little something about this tax um it's
when we say net revenues it's not profit
first off people hear net revenue they
think it's profit in hospitals uh gross
charges is what you see as the in their
in their revenue per type of procedure
but it's really net the net is the net
of that uh after contractuals so Blue
Cross sees the charges but let's say a
chest Stakes way is on there on their
books $100 but Blue Cross is only going
to pay
$50 so that is the contractual
difference so the net in this is really
the net charges not not the net profit I
just wanted to clarify that and it's
really what this whole program is
designed to do is to help the hospitals
with high Medicaid populations it's very
hard to survive with very high Medicaid
prop uh uh population so basically and
and self-pay patients so those hospitals
out of this fund will get more more
Revenue as the Dish payment that was
described than those hospitals in a in a
good uh setting like my Hospital Exit
hospitals in a very good setting there's
not much much uh free care and all that
so uh so that's what the program is
about that's all thank you
very
good uh any further questions or
comments on the Medicaid en question
chairman yes who's that Jim Murphy
representative Murphy go ahead U just a
question maybe they can answer is my
question is have we seen a significant
drop in the uh uh met payments because
of covid I know that a lot of Hospital
util utilizations are way down and the
other question I had is what percentage
of the Met payment coming in Gross is
actually going back in Dish payments to
the contributing hospitals and has that
declined over the years since its
Inception in the early
90s great great question representative
Murphy so for payments um so as I stated
before what's do this month are the
January 15th non-binding estimate
payments were B which is based on the
hospital's fiscal year ending 2020 so
those are flowing in as we speak so
we'll have official numbers probably
next week or by the end of this week to
let you know how much they've decreased
but we do anticipate a decrease based on
uh the covid situation and how the
hospitals have been struggling some as
for the percentage of met payments out
of dish I don't have that answer because
uh DHHS is the one who's responsible for
the dish payments but we could probably
reach out to them and get you some
information on historical dish payments
being made my my my reason for that
second question was that my
understanding when this initially came
out was that the Met payment was made by
the
hospitals it the federal was a one to
one match on it and it was supposed to
go back basically you know keeping the
hospitals hold with regard to the Met
payment and my experience is that that
has actually decreased over time uh
meaning the money is going back to the
hospitals I just wondering if that trend
is
continuing sure we'll get you some
information on that thank you major this
is Chris just to um let the committee
know the Department of Health and Human
Services is speaking to you this
afternoon so I email Karen rounds to
just um maybe have some information
related to the met and the distribution
of that good because um they're going to
be speaking to us at 1:30 this
afternoon all right any further
questions or comments on Medicaid
enhancement taxs
if not next is Nursing Facility quality
assessment thank you so the nursing
facility quality assessment or NF QA is
a 5 a half% tax upon the net patient
services revenue on all nursing
facilities on the basis of patient days
in each facility the assessment is paid
by the nursing facilities as well as
facilities licensed as a specialty
hospital and certified to receive
federal reimbursement as a nursing
facility and F QA is assessed quarterly
with returns due on the 10th of the
month following the quarter in payment
if via check is due on the 15th the
facilities are paying electronically
they do have until the end of the month
to pay those facilities can now file
well this is a 10-year trend of nqa
based on unaudited cash the current five
and a half percent rate applied to all
years in this chart
slide nursing facilities file their
quarterly returns with both the Dr and
HHS they typically pay their assessment
due by electronic funds transfer and
it's important to note that the NF QA
revenue is deposited directly into the
nursing facility trust fund so again
much like met this assessment does not
go into the general education trust
funds outlined there um the commissioner
of HHS is responsible for expending
funds in accordance with RSA
151 d e col 15 the monies in the fund
shall be used to eliminate or reduce to
the maximum extent possible the
difference between the allowable
Medicaid costs derived from the nursing
facility Medicaid Acuity rate setting
system which nursing facilities incur in
providing care to Medicaid residents and
the amount which the state has budgeted
in order to fund that Care Dr is
authorized much like Matt to audit nfq
returns and collect unpaid nqa
liability are there any questions on
nqa yeah I would have thought that on
your 10year
Trend that there would have seen some
effect of the pandemic on
fy20 revenues if not is it going to be
show up in
fy21 and which your
anticipation um currently the um NF QA
um for FY
2021 again right now nfq um facilities
are paying their third uh their second
quarter um payments which are due by the
end of this month but currently NF QA um
is 8.9% above prior fiscal year at this
point and um 16.5% below fiscal year
2021 plan but again on caution with
those numbers we haven't seen all
Revenue come in for January at this
point um we'll no more as the fiscal
year goes on I guess but as of right now
it doesn't seem to be too affected by by
facilities that begs another question is
how's the occupancy rate on these n
nursing facilities is that being
decreasing that's not something that we
have but we more more than happy to look
into that for you and get back to the
Comm on okay Norm can I make a comment
please represent BR yeah just just for
the members uh every every every county
has a county home uh that we're that
we're responsible for overseeing and the
budget and Etc so this is just be aware
that this this affects our County homes
comment any further questions or
comments this is represent elme
representative elme thank you on the
there was a few Year back back when this
got started it's essentially another
Medicaid type thing where you're
transferring money from the nursing
homes that have more paying customers to
the nursing homes that aren't getting
sufficient money from the state to make
up uh which would include our County
homes and and uh there was a big fight
going on in the early days about the
Continuing Care Facilities which have
nursing home sections within them but
have signed a um a pledge that they will
not have any of their members go on to
Medicaid uh so they have no chance of
recuperating anything from it and can
you tell us which on whe who which side
won that
fight
that is the continuing cares did not
want to have to pay
this represent Vol me this is Chris I I
think that's a question that's probably
directed at Department of Health and
Human
Services so again I I'll reach out to
Karen and let her know that that
question may be
coming we were our committee was
involved in in redoing the Met tax when
it was falling apart completely and nine
years ago and then a year or two later
when this was
created Norm can I just jump in real
quick again um go ahead Pat we have five
more minutes yeah I know more topics go
ahead it's just I I was involved in this
10 years nine nine years ago uh where
the ccc's Continuing Care uh residential
communities which are um independent
assisted and then nursing home but they
they they life contracts no Medicaid and
they wanted out of the Met tax uh that
was maybe that was the fight you were
talking about Susan yes but there was no
what happened that that bill got
defeated but short of it that's the
answer okay U do we have any other
questions on this because there's a few
more items to cover in the next five
minutes youtility property tax all right
utility property tax it's a tax rate of
6.6
cents per thousand of value the taxes
value of utility property as determined
by the department on December 1st of
each year for the values as of April
1 so when to file and pay on a for May
1st of each year the company files a
form detailing the company's actual
Financial operating performance since
the prior of April 1st of the preceding
year so final payments for this is are
due January 15th so essentially there
estimate payments made made on prior
evaluations so April June September and
December are on the FI the prior
evaluation and then January 15th we sort
of call a true up return where they pay
the difference from the prior year
valuation to the current
rate on the next slide we have the upt
revenue 10year Trend uh and some of the
things that can affect the factors for
upt are obviously development of newer
renewable energy facilities valuation
utility property or energy pricing
supply and
demand any any questions on
upt questions or comments on utility
property
tax uh then we can go on to the railroad
tax so the railroad tax is a smaller tax
compared to the ones we've previously
discussed um every railroad Railway
Express parlor sleeping or Dining Car
Company operating for profit New
Hampshire pays a railroad tax it's based
on the market value of property's full
and True Value as of April 1st each year
property values and average rates of
Taxation are determined by the Dr onor
before May 1st each year the company
files a form detailing the company's
Financial operating performance since
April 1st of the preceding year payment
is due within 30 days from the date of
um notice of value or tax bill which is
typically due December 15th if those
liabilities exceed $200 estimates equal
to 25% of the tax are do on the 15th day
of April June September and December to
put this in perspective um for fiscal
year 2020
$36,000 in tax revenue was collected
with
Statewide any
questions or comments on this on the
railroad
tax sand none go to the local property
tax right local property tax it's split
into two sections we have the Statewide
education property tax which is swep and
the local property tax for swep the tax
is assessed and collected by
municipalities to be retained for use of
their local school district the tax is
paid by everyone owning real property in
the state the department sets as Lindsay
had stated before all the tax rates for
the state and municipalities so the
department sets the tax rate of a level
suff sufficient to what's in the statute
which is 363 million and then the rate
is set to the nearest half cent
necessary to generate that required
revenue and then for the local property
tax side uh the property tax is B on
based on local assessed valuations and
administered and collected by the
individual towns and cities uh the
majority of the property taxes collected
are based on the market value and then
there's some exemptions in the property
taxes which are listed below happy to
questions I don't i' like to just on ask
her for something for later on and I
asked this last week actually on you
have a major major role in
guaranteeing the fairness of this tax
across the towns and it would be nice to
have a sheet that showed your
Administration on that
level sure we can get you something that
shows
that okay we can deal with that later as
we meet with the Dr because we're
running out of time uh quick on
evacuation gravel tax yes so the
excavation or gravel tax is assessed at
a rate of two cents per cubic yard of
Earth excavated with certain exceptions
it is assessed by and payable to local
assessing
officials um the Dr is responsible for
administering and enforcing the tax tax
which includes activities like educating
Municipal officials checking volumes of
excavated material reporting violations
to local and state officials and
entering any lands that may have been
excavated at any point and notice of
intent to excavate along with a $100
admin fee must be filed with the Dr
prior to excavation and at the beginning
of each tax year which is April 1st for
those operations still in progress
owners must report all Earth excavated
within 30 days of completion within 30
days of that date local assessing
officials must send a tax bill and then
that tax must be paid within 30 days of
it being mailed any questions for the
gravel
tax I don't hear anybody we'll go to the
timber
tax so the timber tax is assessed at a
rate of 10% of the stumpage value at the
time of cutting it is assessed by in
payable to the local assessing officials
much like the gravel tax the only
exceptions are shade and ornamental
trees sugar Orchards Nursery stock and
Christmas trees and um certain amounts
of firewood the Dr is responsible for
admin enforc an attacks which also
includes entering land which there may
be a Timber operation reviewing those
Timber operation records and stopping
any operations in violation reporting
those to local authorities the owner
must file a notice of intent to cut with
Municipal assessing officials with a
copy to the owner logger in the Dr at
the beginning of each tax year April 1st
or for ongoing operations or prior to
commencing each cutting operation the
owners much like the excavation tax must
report all wood or Timber cut within 30
days of completion local assessing
officials assess the tax within 30 days
and then upon mailing that bill the tax
must be paid within 30 days again any
questions with the timber tax okay we'll
go to the next
item okay so I think we've covered all
our taxes this is just a quick slide to
have for your reference it's just the
timing of how dr's money flows in the
top is by month the middle is by quarter
and the the lower section is by annually
and I think the only thing to point out
which Lindsay had point out in the
previous presentation one of the big
ones is indd if you look at indd in the
bottom half the first half of the fiscal
year only brings in 24% of the money and
the second half brings in 76% of the
money so we have um a big chunk of money
coming in for the second half of the
fiscal
year oh and on the next slide this is
just a list of resources um for for your
team and for the new people to at we
have our annual report we have our
transparency page which has some
reporting we have a daily revenue
updates which comes through email which
hopefully everybody on the committee is
receiving at this point we have our tax
expenditure which is on our web page and
then there's also a Dr list serve which
I highly recommend everybody subscribing
to and it essentially gives you alerts
when press releases come out or TI tis
are coming out sends you a notification
uh for those for those items and do you
laws hi this is Caroline I'm gonna take
over for a minute um so before we talk
about revenues it certainly makes sense
to discuss the $30 million anom
anomalous receivable um as part of the
state's year on financial reporting um
the state uh converts revenue from a
cash basis to an acrel basis and in
order to determine acral basis revenues
um the state looks at the first 60 days
of the fiscal year where the underlying
activity had actually occurred in the
prior prior fiscal year um and removes
that from the current year and adds it
back to the prior year um these amounts
are referred to as the 60-day receivable
um and the process for determining the
60-day receivable happens in two phases
preliminary and final um these amounts
are typically fairly consistent from
gear to
year and um as a result we don't really
talk about them um but in this year
there was a difference um first the
amounts for fiscal year 2020 for
business taxes and the indd tax were
more than usual due to the federal due
date change um the federal due date for
personal and business income taxes was
extended from April 15th to July 15th
due to the pandemic um here in New
Hampshire we only extended the due date
to June 15th um because we were mindful
of ensuring revenues were received
during the state's fiscal year as
intended however many of our taxpayers
still filed their New Hampshire State
returns consistent with the federal July
15th due date um and as a result we had
a lot of Revenue received in um the in
this fiscal year rather than in
last um second the amounts for the final
day the final 60-day receivable were
more than the preliminary 60-day
receivable um as a result of incomplete
Revenue data for the month of July at
the time those preliminary amounts were
calculated um these two factors resulted
in the somewhat large $3.8 million in
additional Revenue receip receiv
received in July and August um which
should have been attributable to fiscal
year
2020 these amounts are um listed on the
monthly Revenue focus and included in
revenues received FIS fiscal year to
date reported by us um and are generally
being accounted for when you take a look
at our Revenue estimate ranges as well
they're specifically called out and
there at the bottom you'll see uh the
30.8 million divided amongst the various
administer do you want to briefly um go
summary uh I guess I will take this so
um what you see uh in front of you is
our fiscal year 21 Revenue estimate sign
summary you'll see fiscal year 20 on the
right preliminary acral plus the
anomalous acrel moving to the right
you'll see plan for the year you see our
Dr low and high for each of the taxes of
where we estimate that fiscal year 21
will
land and then we show you both the
dollar amount and the percent percentage
change from the Dr low to plan and then
Dr High to plan so again this is just
where we think fiscal year 21 is going
to land because obviously this will
serve as your base as you build your
Revenue estimates for fiscal years 22
and 23 I will call out at the bottom for
representative abrami based on his
comment last week we're showing you the
amounts of school building aid for
fiscal year 21 what we anticipate the
lchip amount to be typically roughly 3%
and then the amount to the affordable
housing fund um since the numbers up
above are net of those so you could add
those back in before applying your
growth
rates
okay and brief summary of the fy22 and
23 sure for fiscal years 22 and 23
you'll see in the First Column we
included the fiscal year 21 anomalous
receivable um you will want to take that
out of fiscal year 21 before you apply
growth rates for fiscal year 22 and 23
if you were to include it you would
essentially be double counting that
Revenue um so we show you what the 21
anomalous receivable was and then we
remove it from our low and high
estimates for fiscal year 21 in that
second and third orange column and then
we give you growth ranges for fiscal
years 22 a low and a high by tax type
and then fiscal years 23 a low and a
high by tax
type again at the bottom we'll give you
the school building Aid amounts um which
go into M&R the lchip amount which is
part of R and the affordable housing
fund transfer which is also part of R
again so that you can add those back in
prior to applying your growth rates if
that's how you would like to estimate
your
revenues we'll obviously be prepared to
come back whenever the committee is
ready to dive into this in more detail
but we wanted to or we were asked and we
wanted to provide you with our
preliminary thoughts for fiscal years 21
22 and
23 and a few brief words on your rims
system sure so rims are Revenue
information management system is a
30.1 30.2 almost million doll um Capital
project that the Dr is currently
undertaking the goal here is to replace
our current Tims system um which was
implemented in 1990 that system is
Obsolete and limited in its
functionality uh rims will be used
internally here at the department but it
also has a public facing portal which
I'll show you in just a second for
taxpayers and
practitioners um we are doing this in
conjunction with DOI y we have a great
partnership with the Department of
Information Technology and we are
working with a vendor called Fast
Enterprises um for them to implement
their commercial off-the-shelf software
product gen tax which is in many other
states across the United States
implementation is going to be in three
phases each taking about a year and the
total contract with fast is just under
$30
million this is an outline of the three
phases um we have already completed
rollout one which when live on October
28th of 2019 which included the meals
and rentals tax Medicaid enhancement tax
and Nursing Facility quality assessment
in October we went live with our second
roll out our largest roll out uh really
for the business profits tax business
Enterprise tax interest and dividends
tax and communication Services tax that
is on time um even working through the
pandemic and trans transitioning to
remote work we were able to keep that go
live date so we're really proud of the
work that was done there and then
currently we are in the middle of
rollout 3 which will go live at the
beginning of August and that includes
all of our other miscellaneous taxes
tobacco rat upt railroad Timber gravel
Etc and again we are on track to
complete that go live on time as
well lastly this is just um a screenshot
of granite tax connect if you were to uh
go to dr's website and and attempt to
log into GTC this is what you would see
um a few things I would note here um you
can make a payment right from this home
screen you can apply for an application
if you're opening a new restaurant for
instance you can do that right from here
um you can register with us to begin
filing and paying your taxes um you can
also request a certificate such as a
certificate of good standing and you can
report tax fraud to us right from the
homepage as well um this increased
functionality has really been wonderful
for both the Dr and for taxpayers
historically if you wanted to know um
what your estimate payment was last
quarter um if you couldn't remember you
would have to call into our call center
and while those folks are wonderful um
you'd have to call and talk to someone
in order to get that information now if
you register through GTC you can access
your account at any time you can see
your payments you can make a payment you
can file a return and perform another a
number of other functions so this is
really catapulted Dr into the 21st
century in terms of providing
functionality and account access to our
tax
payers okay want to thank Lindsay
Carolyn Melissa and Devin for great
presentations this morning and all the
on all the Dr tax activities going on
explaining the history and where we are
and we'll be getting them back as we do
Revenue estimates and we thank you and
we need to go on to our next presenter
thank you everybody for a great
presentation
Brad and who is the next person up on
your list I just Charlie McIntyre we are
about 10 minutes
behind and the next is Charlie
McIntyre the direct executive director
of The Lottery Commission and he's going
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee this is Charlie McIntyre um
director the natural Lottery with me my
office is our Chief Financial Officer
Jim durus I had forwarded a a
presentation a couple three days ago to
the committee should I share the screen
I have or should is it going to be
shared through um Chris
Shay Brad share your screen if you would
like I could try that I'm not particular
good
it I'll
try do you see it you're already doing
it
yes hey what do you know I went to law
school so um obviously mine will be very
brief compared to my colleague Miss step
um the lottery is comprised of a number
of Revenue sources broken down um
as follows um and after each Revenue
source is an estimate of the revenue we
expect to derive this year from that
source and in cases where we've raised
guidance there'll be brackets and the
amount we expect to increase over what
we had originally estimated based on
various factors we can get into so the
First Source is our jackpot games which
are Powerball Mega Millions and
megabytes uh as many of you know these
are highly visible games very profitable
um we had just had a giant jackpot run
for Powerball Mega Millions which to
give you an
example in one week we would do six
million in sales in Powerball milon
Millions where an average week would be
700,000 so it's a you know a nine
sometimes 10x Factor growth so for the
for the FIS year 21 we expect
to conservatively do 21.5 million
profit in those three product
lines following next is Tri State Games
megabuck is a trate game but we also
sell up a number of other ones uh pick
three pick four which are daily number
of games uh Gimme Five which is a pick
five number game and fast play which is
a terminal product we share all those
with Vermont and Maine they're all very
stable very dependable very normalized
uh we expect $9.7 million in profit with
those
Kino is a game uh you folks approved in
2018 uh we launched in 2018 which was
the fastest launch of Kino in the US
History uh and that had been enjoying
tremendous growth preco uh when bars
closed down as you can imagine uh sales
plummeted sales have rebounded nicely um
and are accelerating so we estimate
another quarter million dollars profit
over and above our Revenue estimates of
November uh so 7 75 million for Kino
this fiscal year uh Lucky for Life is a
multi-state game we share with a number
of states um the top prize never changes
so the sales are very stable $1.6
million profit there insta tickets is
the bulk of what we sell um they are
sold at retail they're throughout our
1200 retail network uh have been
available for many many years they
stable in almost every lottery in the US
um and they sales have been increasing
so we're raising guidance a million
dollars to $53 million for scratch
ticket sales and
profitability next would be mobile and
internet which you folks approved in
2018 it has been the fastest growing
area of the lottery
um you can buy Powerball Mega Millions
and you can buy scratch tickets through
your mobile
applications and we had estimated $10
million profit in November we now
estimate $1 13 million profit profit uh
for this fiscal year sports betting
which is our newest product line uh
launched in
2019 uh December 30th
um this fiscal year sales have that have
been have been higher than we
anticipated um but we're still nervous
as you can imagine we're unclear as to
the sports
betting map or the sports betting
calendar as it were uh obviously with
covid but given the acceleration and the
growth we've enjoyed um by way of
example we had a record
December um in terms of sports betting
activity we estimate $1 million profit
for sports betting for this fiscal year
and finally uh is charitable gambling
which involves all of the charitable
functions of the State uh bingo lucky s
and includes also some small version of
horse racing simoc cast um that function
is really regulatory we don't really get
involved in promotion um that is
generates about $3 million so that all
being said Mr chairman members of the
committee uh the lottery is Raising
guidance uh $10 million to this fiscal
year of10 million. five5 million for
revenue for this fiscal year um well and
above what we had originally estimated
and I'll stop there answer any questions
you want to have if that works for you
Mr chairman uh yes it does um
let me pull up and representative major
panelists should be able to raise their
hands now if people want to go ahead and
try that great okay questions raise your
first representative browny you have to
unmute
yourself uh Charlie It's Pat um uh for
the Powerball and mega miliams can you
tell the committee how much we make per
ticket sold how that works certainly um
Powerball bam millions are our most
profitable games out of every dollar
sold 40.5 cents approximately is profit
and that goes directly to the state so
it's I want to say our most erratic
product because some years like I said
some weeks the jackpots a billion
dollars and some weeks the jackpots 20
and the growth in sales is exponential
in those High jackpot weeks so our sales
depend on having a number of large
jackpots in a given year and our
revenues reflect the number of jackpots
we have in a given year because like I
said it is our most profitable product
um 40.5 cents give or take uh every
dollar we
sell thank you
representer Amanda
Gro um thank you I just had one question
while you're going to the revenue
sources um for example you would say
like the jackpot games 21.5 million was
profit or is that just Revenue it's
profit every number on your screen
representative the question that's our
what we expect a profit and obviously
these are estimates because our expenses
vary by profit by product um but you
know obviously we don't account for
every staff member's time as against
each product you know like with like a
billing sheet but these are all profit
me represent you're going to have to
unmute yourself sorry uh quick just
quickly on for instance jackpot games
the first one
21.5 is what you have raised your
projection two and 2.4 is the amount you
raised it correct yes representative yes
thank
you uh further
questions or
Elliot you'll have to unmute yourself
hat okay um Charles I uh wondered how do
you account for this the success is it
because of the the the corona effect
people are being staying home more often
and they're bored and they need a little
excitement in their life how do you
account for your success
I mean certainly um I like to think we
did had something to do with it
representative um you know we're
certainly if you look to our neighbors
our growth rate is far and away faster
than any else around us so I certainly
you kinded lot the folks here I do think
there have been a number of additional
citizens of the state who would not be
here ordinarily that have accounted for
sales like for example Instant tickets
sales have increased but not acoss the
state uniformly it's been really pockets
of growth and so like ala Lakes Region
you've seen a significant growth of
sales I think a lot of folks have moved
up here during covid it wouldn't be
ordinarily and that's accounting for
some of our sales growth as well and I
also think there's a lot of
entertainment options that don't exist
anymore and folks are looking for
something to do it's you know this
entertaining so to your point yes part
covid part we're pretty good at what we
do
thank you charliie relative to the
sports betting with the pandemic going
on now it doesn't seem like that
effective no no we had a real bad dip in
March through June when there was
virtually nothing to bet on all sports
had
cancelled um but there's been an
exuberance essentially of um just happy
sports are back and I think that's a
counter for a lot of it we also derive a
tremendous amount of activity from
Massachusetts at our facilities in
Manchester and Seabrook um I would
estimate 75 80% of our Revenue in
Seabrook is from Massachusetts in terms
of sports betting activity so I think I
can't personally underestimated how much
interest there was
um in that we also even on the mobile
side representative major
20 plus percent of our revenues come
from Massachusetts folks driving across
the border to place a bet at you know
the mall of Nashua or this traffic
circle in Portsmouth they stop in the
liquor store in the parking lot place a
bet then drive back to mass or Maine so
we've seeing a lot of that as well more
so than I
anticipated okay I don't see any other
hand so why don't you continue okay
certainly so this is just a general over
viw um of the lottery sales by game over
the last 10 years and as you can see the
bulk of it has been scratch tickets it's
faren away the most in terms of gross
dollars these are this is a graph by
gross sales uh most of what we sell is
scratch tickets um and really it's so
really now our sales would be in order
of size would be scratch tickets and
then Kino followed by Powerball and then
Mega Millions
um sports betting is obviously a big
number in terms of how much betting
activity we do but it's a very low
margin activity sports betting for the
state really
is well profits around 7% and we split
5050 and here is sort of the lottery to
Nutshell I wanted you to have this
number because it is it's uh page four
on this uh presentation but it's in our
comprehensive annual financial report
which rolls up into the state uh
financial report and here are all the
numbers in the nutshell um as you can
see we've enjoyed tremendous growth over
the last 10 years and obviously this
year now that we're estimating $120
million um we have a very like very
possible chance to essentially double
our net revenues over the last 10 years
which we're obviously very proud of um
and in some cases you can see like
scratch tiets as you go across that line
tremendous
growth you know from $161 million in
2011 to last year was $272 million and
this year I can tell you will exceed 300
million um but contrast that with say
for example the Powerball Mega Millions
line where in 2019 those combined for 60
you know 69 million and last year they
combine for 41 million so like I said
they're quite ER RCT and that's based on
jackpot sizes and so when we Revenue
estimate scratch tickets you know we can
tell you within $100 give or Tech what
the profit will be for a year Powerball
Mega Millions it varies wildly by year
so
um I'll leave this and
so obviously our Trends would be
uh we expect growth continued on digital
platforms both internet lottery and
sports betting um the biggest impact to
our sales generally speaking
particularly at retail is fuel prices um
we do 52% of our sales at retail at
places that sell gas too so um gas
prices have a direct impact on our sales
more so than essentially any other
function and then if Massachusetts
passes sports betting we would expect a
dramatic impact on our revenues so those
are our Trends Mr chairman members of
the committee I'll put that slide back
up because it obviously contains the
most data and your membership may have
the most questions regarding anything on
that sheet if that's okay with you
that's fine questions from the
committee representative
tuer yes um could you talk about problem
gambling a little bit I hadn't realized
how enormous the lottery sales were is
that something that people
become habituated to addicted to in the
same way as we worry about other forms
of gaming certainly no there's no
question if you look at any of the
research that we follow and we do um one
to one and a half percent of the people
who play who gamble are technically
problem gamblers and in a state like New
Hampshire you know that's thousands of
people people so there is an issue
obviously with problem gambling um there
is a council that was set up by you
folks a couple years back which is Staff
U which is appointed folks uh by the
governor approved by the executive
Council set up
to address it they're in the process now
of an
RFP um to contract for
services um but we are candidly behind
some other states in terms of our
addressing the issue could I ask a
followup please followup the reason I'm
asking is there's some other uh gaming
opportunities or uh bills that are
coming forward and so it would be
probably a good idea to have a good
handle on how they RS how the uh
requests for proposals are coming along
and what kind of timeline uh we're
talking about to deal with problem
gamblers because I think that will be
one of the first questions people will
want to know the answers
to okay certainly I can I can arrange
for that as it comes up representative
Tucker thank
committee hey you did a great job
Charlie I tried to be fast I knew you
guys were
behind matter of fact you we're right on
schedule now thank you very good thank
you good to see you representative um
everybody Mr chairman thank you all
right keep up the good
work all right we're right on schedule
so
11:30 the next is the liquor
commissioner Joseph Malika who was
chairman of the electric commission and
Tina demz the Chief Financial
Officer and they that time
now you want to share your screen
I'm allowing Tina to talk I don't know
if one of the the phone numbers is uh
commissioner
mik we're in the same room we're in the
same room okay so I'll make you a
you I don't seem to have the option of
screen
should uh Brad do you know
why I has promoted them to a panelist
they should be able to do that now I I
did too maybe we crossed ass
bigger one slide at a time right can can
bigger
Brad can you help them
out oh if they go to I me display
settings
maybe you go to display set you may be
able to make it full
screen may need to deselect the myang
glass as
well
it's pretty sorry hold on I put it on
presentation does that come up on full
screen no there's two
screens two
screens
just
o same
thing
yeah select display settings is there an
screen up at the top you have a display
that
that's that's better is that better yes
okay okay
that
okay so we're ready to go if you are Mr
chairman yes take it away okay members
of the committee good morning for the
record I'm Joseph Mica chairman of the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission and with
us is our CFO Tina
deir you'll see on slide two the
statutory responsibility that guides our
everyday work here at the Liquor
Commission irsa 176 colon
3 and on side three Tina will take you
through our Revenue history and then
I'll get back to speaking with you thank
you very much all right to start out we
wanted to start out showing the net
profit history of the commission and
then with each slide we're going to
break down to what makes up our profit
numbers and our transfers the first
chart shows the net profit growth since
the commission started in 1935 in the
commission's 85 years of operation it's
earned over 4 billion in net profit
the other chart is just the last six
years of actual net profit from
fy14 at 48.7 million to
154.50 million in
fy20 and year-to date for fy21 we're at
89.3 million of which we've transferred
75.3 million to the general fund and 14
million to the granted Advantage um to
HHS which I'll explain further on in the
slide
slides this next slide is our Revenue
broken down into our three main
categories we have beer tax and permits
which is a 30 cents tax on a gallon per
gallon sold or transferred from retail
or to the public from authorized
licenses liquor and wine revenue is the
sale of wine spirits and accessories
through our outlet stores and warehouses
to retail customers such as on premise
licenses which are restaurants lounges
and off- premise licenses the grocery
stores and the
markets the the last category is other
Revenue which is primarily our license e
fees but it also includes direct
shipping permits Lottery and other
miscellaneous
Revenue this next slide is the FY 16 to2
annual um actual with FY um 21 to 23
projections the annual growth from 16 to
20 was less than 1% or around 1.2
million
annually fy20 had a high Revenue growth
from pandemic purchases it was a 2.2%
growth or $5 million
increase you'll see an even more
significant increase projected for fy21
which is about 4.6% or 10.3 million and
this is primarily a result of not
running uh the promotional carb programs
that we've done in Prior years which was
the spend 150 and received a $25 gift
card last year we ran it in July
November and March um the last one was
done in March of 20120 and this actually
equated to a $10 million increase in our
gross profit in uh projected in
fy21 fy22 and 23 projections the growth
rate is slightly higher than the prior
year normal growth rate at 1.3 and 1.5%
which equates to about three and $3.5
increase on slide
six this is the um this provides revenue
and expense history that makes up our
net profit which you can see at the top
of each
bar um fy21 to FY 23 projections are all
around $160
million this is because um from an
expense side we're we also have growth
um primarily in fy21 the increas is for
salaries and benefits of $2 million in
it and debt which is increasing about a
million dollars fy22 and 23 projections
uh we not only have our normal operating
expense growth but we also have
additional expenses associated with our
new POS system and POS and back office
system and we also have an additional
million on slide seven this just shows
the total net profit broken down by
liquor and wine and beer which are the
have okay and on
slide eight and in conjunction with it
slide nine if you could you can look at
both of them together um this slide is
important because it shows the history
of the transfer to Health and Human
Services for the for first the alcohol
Abuse Prevention and treatment fund and
then the granted Advantage Healthcare
trust fund that transferred to um
HHS so you can see in
fy16 we had to transfer 3.2 million and
that was at a 1.7% of our prior year
gross profit and each year that
percentage has changed to the point in
FY 20 it was uh 5% which equated to $10
million in
fy21 we not only have the 5% transfer of
$10 million but there is another statue
which is um the RSA 126 AA colon 3 where
HHS can request uh additional funds if
the granted Advantage fund is running
short so this year they're requesting an
additional $8.5 million be transferred
for a total of $18.5 million being
transferred to HHS Which is less um
that's being transferred to the general
fund and you can see that whole
breakdown on um slide nine so in
fy21 we're projecting to transfer $129
million to the general fund um for
liquor and wine 13.2 million for the
beer transfer and then we're
transferring the 18.5 million to HHS the
fy22 and 23 projections only include the
5% so about the $10 million because we
um we might have um Health and Human
Services asking within each of those
fiscal years for additional funds but
for now we have to only put in what's
5% so if we go to slide 10 we wanted to
provide um a breakdown of our sales you
have for fy6 you want to you to slide
slide nine oh I'm
sorry I was flipping my page and I
didn't flip okay so I'll go back this is
the slide that shows the breakdown for
transfers so you can see the transfer
136.34 for beer tax and then the 10.9
for HHS I'm sorry I forgot to turn the
page and that 10.9 is just an estimated
number right 5% of the prior year gross
profit you can see in fy21 the estimated
number and the additional number
that they've asked for on the previous
slide making up the $8 million5
18.5
okay so the next two slides we just
wanted to provide um some of our sales
breakdown so on this slide you can see
fy6 to 20 our retail and on premise
sales um for fy20 were higher than
normal and on premise was down due to
um fy20 retail was
158.3 Million up 46.5 million or
88.7% off premise was 114 million up 5.5
million or 5% and on premise was 62.2
19% we go to excuse me
this um slide shows the breakdown by
spirits and wine category by our re by
our customer types so Spirit sales are
60% of our business at
44.4 million in fy20 retail is 90% of
that at 410 million on premise is 9%
42.1 million and off- premise is 1% or
2.3 million on the wine side they make
up 40% of our business at 33.7 million
retail is 56 or 172 million and off
premise is 37% or 112 million and on
premise is 7% or 20
million and at this point I will hand it
back over to the
chairman and just a just a note for for
the committee is that we've seen our our
off our off I'm sorry our on premise
Partners vary between
40% off to about 25% off so their sales
have suffered tremendously as we all
know the restaurants are struggling
during this pandemic so we've seen them
off at as much as 45 46% and right at
this point they're off still by about
25% so on slide 12 are Outlet locations
we have 69 Outlets 60 are least to
approximately 520,000 Square ft we have
nine state-owned Outlets that are listed
they're approximately 142,000 square fet
and the state owned Outlets account for
about 160 million or
26% of our total sales and you'll see
the map on the left our Outlet locations
with curbside that we've just launched
in March so you can get on to our
website order your product and then uh
pay for it at pay for it electronically
and pick it up at the store we started
with two stores in May of 2020 we're now
up to 10 stores this week as of
yesterday we just launched uh two more
stores in Bedford and Tilton and on
February 8th we'll launch two more
stores in Kean and epsom those stores
are presently at just under 1.5 million
in curbside sale
on page
14 you'll see the top 15 locations
across the state and the ones with the
asteris are the state-owned locations
that are in the top 15 stores so the top
15 stores account for 51% of our sales
and all other stores account for 49% of
our
sales you'll see on page six I'm sorry
on page 15 the new outlet at the
Portsmouth traffic circle year-to dat
sales are 19.4 million and you'll notice
the sales increase in that new location
is up
14.1% on page 16 a new outlet location
in Lancaster which was a combination
consolidation of a store in West
umberland and in
Lancaster sales are 1.6 million they're
up
47.2% on 17 our new store in do
summersworth line that was a
consolidation of two stores the old do
and summersworth stores year-to dat
sales are 7.7 million and that's an
increase of
19.1% our new outlet in West Lebanon on
page 18 sales year-to date are 10.5
million that was just a transfer to a
new store new location sales increase of
22.4%
and our new outlet in Tilton which was a
consolidation of our stores in Belmont
and Franklin year-to date 4.3 million in
sales an increase of
16% so you can see clearly see through
the numbers that our consolidation and
branding efforts are working
tremendously on page 20 these are the
upcoming Outlet locations they're listed
on the left Epson was open last Friday
and we just signed a deal in Claremont
that will open in 2020 2022 in the
spring so those are the new locations
that'll be coming online uh with our
branding in
place on page 21 we have the outlets
that we closed this year these were
older underperforming Outlets that no
longer fit our brand model of excellent
shopping experience a large amount of
SKS and PE are just a great shopping
experience that I'm sure that everyone's
experienced as they've been in our new
Outlets these Outlets unfortunately
didn't cut didn't cut the mustard so
they're no longer with us on page 22
you'll see some new initiatives and our
new website that'll be launched uh or
that was launched in September of 2020
you can go on there's bottle shots you
can walk through our whole inventory you
can order the product on the website you
can have it delivered curbside to your
car and direct shipping which is part of
sv14 on the initiatives on the bottom
will be launched in the fall and then
you'll be able to order the product and
have it delivered right to your door in
state to start with and then in the 13
states around the nation that allow us
to Direct ship into their homes so
that's initiatives moving forward into
2021 and
2022 and we would be happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have of
us thank you Mr chairman questions from
the
committee represent
Aly thank you Mr chairman um I was
wondering how long it takes to pay off
the B funding from the new stores and
provide a net gain in the transferred
profits the most of the new stores that
we've done have been a partnership with
the landlord so we amortize um the fit
up costs into our rent and that gets
paid off with additional square footage
over a 10year period the only stores
that we've done that we own is the
Portsmith store and the Hampton stores
that will be coming up so no longer do
we do we ask for appropriation to build
these stores we partner with our
business partners our landlord we add
about between
$220 to
$268 a square foot on the first 10 years
of our 20-year lease then that that cost
is paid off a lot of the times our rent
goes down and we continue for our
20-year lease so there's no output of
cash from the state or the Liquor
Commission to build these stores it's
all done on a squarep put percentage
basis that's added into the cost of our
lease for the first 10
Tucker representative Tucker you have to
unmute
yourself thank you um
could you tell me how you are managing
to do so well against the Massachusetts
stores a couple of years ago you talked
about how Massachusetts has changed its
Viewpoint towards liquor and had become
much more competitive and how is that
working for New Hampshire and
Massachusetts
together well uh it's it's not working
together representative uh quite frankly
uh we are in competition with them uh
when Governor uh Patrick was in he
changed the liquor license owning liquor
licenses in uh Massachusetts from three
licenses up to 10 in 2020 so that that
brought in Total Wine and Spirits the
furthest North they had been at that
point was Connecticut they have six
stores in Mass Massachusetts now they
have
213 stores nationwide and they do over
$3 billion in sales a year but they are
a private label uh retailer so they they
come up with their own labels their own
wines and they put them in their stores
they do carry nationally advertised
Brands like the New Hampshire liquor and
wine outlets do but they're not nearly
as competitive in pricing as as we have
been able to be when they first came
into the market they were they were
running a lot of lost leaders which was
driving some of our traffic cross border
but you can only do that for a period of
time there was a number of lawsuits in
Massachusetts against them some some
they prevailed some they didn't but they
were selling product below cost which
they can no longer do uh obviously our
branding initiative started 10 years ago
so we
were ahead of them being in
Massachusetts uh our brand is recognized
our value is recognized and we still we
still as a retailer recognize that over
50% of our business comes from crossb
and about 23% of that is from
Massachusetts so we clearly Market to
that uh to to those individuals in
Massachusetts and we welcome them coming
Set uh thank you Mr chairman and I'm not
too sure if the commissioner is prepared
for this question but I'm just
reflecting back to what was just asked
of Lottery and uh first of all thank you
for the great job that that the Liquor
Commission is doing but I'm curious if
you track in any way problem
drinking and and if you could maybe uh
give us a little background on that if
that is the case
well all of that is tracked and any
information that we get is is tracked
through our enforcement Division and I'd
be happy to share the information that
we have that's public information with
the committee but it's not something
that I have in front of me here at this
moment thank you so much so you can
share that with us next time we meet
which won't be too too far from now okay
thank you Mr chairman uh any further
questions of the Liquor
Commission oh you did a great job and
and keep the growth going thank you very
much Mr chairman members of the
committee we appreciate that we have a
great team here and everyone works
together and we recognize uh how
important we are to the state as a
revenue source and we take that uh that
charge very seriously so thank
you thank you and for the committee
what we're going to do now is we're
going to take a break and come
back at one
o'clock to listen to the judicial branch
followed by the Department of Health and
Human Services and securities and then
the Department of
Justice and Brad we recommend that they
don't leave the system but uh yeah I
would recommend that people just mute
themselves and
um turn their cameras off and I will put
up
a I'll share my screen right now is
saying that we're on a lunch break till
will and then represent Brony has a has
his hand up yeah representative laughman
you
there represent lofman yes I am yeah but
you weren't on when we first started we
we we took a we asked a question when
everybody signed on uh going to be
remote or in person on
Thursday remote okay thank you and is
representative Nunes I don't think
you're there I'm I'm here sir I joined
just a little while ago I was presenting
a bill in another committee I'm sorry
I'm late are you gonna are you gonna be
in person on Thursday or remote I should
be in person sir okay thank you we're
all set Norm okay so everybody have a
great lunch make sure that you uh mute
your video and mute your I do have my
hand up um representative oh
representative southw I'm sorry I didn't
see that yeah I just wanted to make sure
I do have to do some other things with
my computer should I just use the zoom
invitation again when I'm
done I would think so Brad that is
correct the zooming should still work
okay great I'll do that thank
[Music]
you all right then we'll see you
you
for
e
hey Brad we'll give another minute for
board
okay
Brad this is Jenny garlo Brad yes
representative
gal I accidentally shut my computer and
had to log back in can you make me the
co-host again please do that right
now we don't want to lose
techie yeah I ruined your raised hand
function this morning that's how techy I
am oh no I didn't do it I don't
know I'm not entir why that happened but
I guess there was a setting that is need
to be checked um that you know it's a
committee yeah we were really out of
order weren't we I mean not exactly
hey Norm Pat Norm hey Pat you're gonna
have to raise your volume right give
here we go again can hardly hear you
okay I'll talk up for now um just see
have the total eight eight G to be in
person on Thursday and um and uh 16
remote Pat you're going to have to raise
your
volume
maybe Brad can help you on that
so you should be able to do that if you
go to your microphone at the bottom of
the
screen and select the
carrot little arrow and then select
audio settings you should be able to um
increase the volume on your speakers
when
tell me when you're ready
Pat well I'm having trouble finding the
audio settings
um so on my computer he said eight in
person and
16 uh not yep
virtual so try these up here
Pat all right I
up in this section of your keyboard on
the top there yes there you can it looks
like a little
megaphone and one of them shuts it off
one of them turns it down and the other
one turns it
up they're all different yeah they are
they're all slightly
different what kind of a device are you
on I'm on a d laptop okay so if you um
move your pointer to the bottom of your
of the screen
do you see a microphone at the bottom
left hand corner mhone yep if you select
the carrot next to it the little um
triangle next to it you see an option
for audio settings you know what well I
don't have an arrow I don't have a I
don't have a there's no arrow to the
right of it tiny one just a little one
like that no I just clicked on it I got
microphone I me the screen popped up all
right so if you click on that if you
click on the little on the Arrow you
select audio settings if if there is an
option for
that no I didn't do it that way I just
clicked on the microphone and I got a
screen popped up he wants you to click
on the little
arrow it's a stylized Arrow no I don't
have that on mine you have to go to
audio
setting if you got your uh if you got
the mic screen up you can see a on the
the second paragraph down it says
microphone you can move your volume up
there think that's the screen you're
looking
at yes say
microphone uh apps
a no and you're not seeing the arrow
next to the um button for the microphone
itself Zoom call itself
yeah within the screen I think if you're
on the zoom screen
yes yeah you got
it what I didn't do
anything mine computer made a
noise so if you go on to the zoom screen
on Zoom screen and I got the bar on the
bottom all right do you see a microphone
on the left on the left
side way over on the left oh near the
near the okay yeah I got it if there's a
little arrow next to it if you click on
settings see it's a stylized Arrow yes I
have the mute button with the microphone
and I T there's a little arrow going up
on that I that's it yes you want the
arrow to the
right just to the right between stop
video and mute yeah I clicked on that
let Brad give him the
instructions and then I got it says
select a microphone that's clict select
the speaker yep all the way to the
bottom there settings bottom Bingo yep
if there's a section on the microphone
setting volume turn that up it's pretty
oh wait a
minute you have to be in audio
settings yeah I'm I'm there Norm we lost
your
video oh I have it I have it up to the
top I have it up to the
maximum input
level I have it set to the
maximum we can hear okay I think we need
to I know yeah this is how to move on
you can continue working on that okay we
need to get started
um since we're still
connected we're going to be here from
the judicial branch Christopher kading
is the director of Administrative Office
of the courts and he'll be joined with
Donna Raymond the budget director so
yours is Christopher Raymond
there yeah they were yes thanks
representative major they were just
letting me in uh can you hear me now we
can hear you that's great um your audio
is good so I'm uh grateful to be joined
by Donna Raymond our fiscal manager
she's the brains of the
presentation all
yours
I noticed Donna Raymond is is muted on
both
the audio
and the uh
video believeing her screen right now is
that
correct I'm sharing my screen can you
see our presentation yes yes yes and
you yes okay good afternoon again I
apologize um but thank you um I am the
fiscal manager for the judicial branch
and also with us today is Chris keading
the director of the administrative
office of the courts we are not in the
same room together um we are both
working remotely I believe uh thank you
again for an opportunity to discuss our
um our revenues that are
unrestricted uh we certainly don't have
the revenue volumes that um some of our
other agencies have I was listening to
liquor presentation and lotteries but
you know I'd like to think every penny
counts we're more around the $13 million
range each year but I thought I would
start by just providing an overview of
the different types of unrestricted
revenues that the court collect and if
certainly if you have any questions um
chime in and then we would just discuss
um the past fiveyear history of those
revenues and what factors we think will
influence um our projections for the
upcoming
bium
so the judicial branch uh consists of
supreme Superior and circuit courts and
we collect revenues through um a number
of different means but primarily fines
as well as entry fees to file motions
requests and other things we also have a
fairly significant portion of
unrestricted Revenue revenues that we
call other that are primarily records
research
fees so in terms of the fines that we
collect it's primarily motor vehicle and
criminal fines both we and the
department of safety collect motor
vehicle F uh if you get a plea by mail
motor vehicle fine you have the option
to just pay the fine directly to the
Department of Safety in which case that
Revenue shows up on their book but if
you choose to contest your fine or if
the fine is such that you cannot pay it
via plea by mail you then will get um a
court date and then you can State your
case and if you are found guilty then
the courts will collect that that
Revenue
we also impose criminal
fines and those fines can be collected
directly at the courts or if the court
has so ordered the fine um will be
collected by the Department of
Correction via one of their field
offices when that takes place I believe
the process is every two weeks um an
electronic file is sent over to the
court indicating the case and the amount
of money that were that was collected on
that case and then our court staff
manually enter that information on our
books so the revenue is actually
reported on our books but it is
Correction in terms of fines there are
penalty assessments that are levied on
many of our fines uh for criminal
offenses motor vehicle um as well as
violations of Municipal ordinances and
penalty assessment is $2 or 24% of the
fine I don't know that we've ever had a
fine that would get you a $2 penalty
assessment usually your fine is in the
$100 or up range so on a $100 fine the
penalty assessment would be $24 the
total fee you would pay is
$124 of that the $100 is the fine
portion goes to the general fund the
penalty assessment portion of it splits
So currently um 66 or 23% of the penalty
assessment is deposited to the general
fund and that is as of fiscal year
2017 uh it used to be that that portion
of the penalty assessment went to police
standards and training but with the
declining Revenue in general of penalty
assessment it was becoming difficult for
um police standards and training to have
enough Revenue to support its operations
as a result they are now I believe 100%
generally funded so we send that Revenue
now to the general fund to help offset
what the general fund uh provides to
police ERS and training for them to
operate the other 2third um is split
evenly so one excuse me the other
onethird so um half of that goes to the
judicial branches it dedicated fund and
the other half of it goes to Department
of Justice's victims assistance fund and
just as an aside um the it dedicated
fund um has recently as well had its
share of issues in terms of having
adequate revenues to support its
operations and that has been documented
in the last few annual it dedicated fund
reports that we have filed with the
legislature um the we had proposed a few
different solutions to that ultimately
it was decided that General funds would
augment the shortfall so that has
happened in this last bium and we are
bium so in terms of um collection
Effectiveness so we are not a collection
agency however we do have issues with
people not paying their fines so we have
a few mechanisms that we employ to try
to get people to pay what they are owed
to the
state um so individuals who pay fail to
pay court-ordered motor vehicle fines
are defaulted so their license is
suspended so Department of Safety will
send a warning notice to the
individual if they continue to not pay
then their driver's license and
registration are suspended we also have
reciprocity in a lot of States so if
they're actually not from this state and
they still get the fine we can suspend
their license in the state in which they
hold their license and if they are
defaulted there is a $50 administration
fee that needs to be paid um to to clear
that
default in terms of other types of
collection Effectiveness um we do also
issue arrest orders um for unpaid fines
in misdemeanor and spell IND cas cases
there is a um a electronic repository of
that information that a police officer
can look up uh and act on it if he
becomes aware of it uh and then we also
try to discourage Time payments again
you're taking your fund you're splitting
it up into smaller pieces we try to
discourage that um and in so doing we
hopefully lower the uncollected fine
balance and we shorten the average
collection
time entry fees is another big part of
the unrestricted revenues that the
courts collect they are set by Court
rule so they are not set in statute the
courts determine the entry fee amounts
and they range um from $45 to around
$225 and small claims is very common uh
civil cases family landlord tenant those
types of um entry fees are very common
for the
court and 64% of Entry fees are
deposited to the general fund and then
the remaining 36% um is split two ways
30% goes to the it dedicated
fund again which the judicial branch
controls and then six% is sent to
facilities escrow and that is also on
our book and Facilities escrow is just
money that's there in case we have some
um type of facilities um Improvement or
repair that needs to get done and there
are no other funds for it we will go to
that Fund in conjunction with on the
Bureau of Courts
facilities
um just as a note um some filing fees
can be waved that will affect revenues
um judges have the option to wave filing
fees if a person can demonstrate that
they cannot afford uh to pay their fee
because again this is about access to
Justice uh We've also noted uh when we
do increase Revenue uh filing fee amount
it tends to result in an increased
number of requests for a waiver of the
fee I believe the last time we
increased our filing fees was back in
2014 I want to say I'm not exactly sure
but it's been a while since we've
actually adjusted um filing fee
amounts and then as I mentioned earlier
another big portion of our unrestricted
revenues falls into what we call other
fees and right now records research fees
it ranges between probably 65 and
75% of what deposits to other fees and
as I've noted in the last proba few
years of giving this presentation uh
before house weighs and means there has
been talk of making online uh public
access to um to records research fees
and that would obviously affect our our
ability to collect revenue for it so
just wanted to put that out there again
I haven't heard anything that's really
happening with it but it may be
something we'll be dealing with in the
future and then motions and petitions
are another portion of what deposits
into other fees and those range from
$250 we also charge a $25 search charge
on many of our civil and family case um
filings but we don't in certain case
types so criminal juvenile um small
claims domestic violence those types of
things but that $25 search charge again
deposits to the general find in this
other fees category we also charge a $25
setup fee for Time payments that also
deposits um as unrestricted fees in in
this other fees
category this next slide is just a
summary of the different types of
unrestricted revenues that the court
collect by um revenue account and a
description of it with some history as
well and next slide is sort of the year
history of these different um
unrestricted revenue streams and I did a
compound annual growth rate as well to
kind of gauge how the funds have done
and default fees collected by safety
have actually remained fairly stable and
again that's the $50 fee similar to ours
that if you've defaulted if you paid
safety with a bad check or something in
order to reinstate you have to pay that
$50 fee so again it's remained
remarkably stable um over the last five
years bar exam fees I think also for the
most part will remain the same and just
as a caveat I think the name of that
account is bar exam fees we do not
actually collect the fees for the bar
exam any longer but there are I think
$10 fees for a um an a good standing
that the courts require if you're going
to litigate a case in this state that
type of thing that's what that revenue
is and then uh the E filing search
charge that's either a 10 or $20 SE
charge that is tacked onto the um the
filing that is done
online and you can see sort of the the
growth there though is due to ramp up so
you can see in fiscal year 2016 we had
less case types that were online than
you had in 18 19 and 20 and I think it's
kind of stabilized at this point New
Hampshire has mandatory um filing for
those case types that are available
online
so now that we've had all the case types
that are going to be online for a while
I think you will see that remain fairly
stable in the next couple of fiscal
years if we were to uh introduce other
case types online you would then see an
increase in that Revenue stream interest
is obviously so small it doesn't really
have much of an impact even though it
went from $33 in 2016 to about a dollar
into school year 20 I'm not too worried
about that decline um fines um have
decreased uh around 20% year-over-year
since fiscal year
2016 one of the things that did have a
big impact on that was what we called
the decriminalization of marijuana
because a lot of those fines that were
associated with um possession of
marijuana were fairly High $500 and up
with the um decriminalization of
marijuana even when there is a fine
involved it tends to be much smaller so
it did have quite a significant impact
um you can see between fiscal year 17
and fiscal year 18 and then a little bit
more into
19 the next category is bail forfeiture
and that one is a little hard to predict
because that's all dependent upon human
behavior who forfeits their bail because
they didn't show up for their court
hearing so I don't really know how one
can predict that very well so but it's
around it's range from2 you know
$76,000 to around 111,000 but again it
will vary I think year to year tough to
predict that one entry fees um have
remained fairly stable again I think at
the onset of the pandemic the first few
months throughout April May and June I
think everybody was reeling from the
impact of it trying to adjust and
understand uh how it would impact things
so we did see a dip um in fiscal year 20
in the last quarter but I think we're
starting to see them rebound
um those things have stabilized a bit
default fees collected by the courts
again that's that $50 excuse me $50 fee
should somebody um pay their Court fine
with a bad check or not show up for
their hearing whatever they have to pay
that additional $50
fee other fees again that has remained
um remarkably strong I think um over uh
the fiscal years and I think part of it
is I think the economy has done still
fairly well and we've all suffered
because of the pandemic but I think New
Hampshire has fared fairly well um and
also in terms of housing I think housing
remains strong and so records research
fees are requested I think a lot of
times for um looking to rent to somebody
or looking to hire someone so we've seen
fairly stable in that line and then
there's uh miscellaneous sales and
revenue and that has actually gone down
quite a bit and that was due to a change
in our procedure with those funds um it
used to be that we would um we would
have funds that were unclaimed so people
paid bail or whatever they paid and for
whatever reason we couldn't locate the
owner of that money it used to be that
after three tries of not being able to
locate the owner we would automatically
send that money over as Revenue to the
general fund in this miscellaneous
revenue account we realized then that we
were not following statutes as regard to
how we should be treating that money we
now as of November um
2017 we hold that money as unclaimed for
three years in an escrow account then if
we were not able to locate the owner
after that three-year period it then
becomes abandoned property right and
then it will deposit to the general fund
we're now getting to that three-year
Mark and we actually did an analysis
last week we don't have any monies
actually in the next few months uh we've
been able to return funds to people but
in April we're going to have money that
has aged three years and will then be
deposited to the general fund and you'll
see on the next slide I've been able to
do an analysis to get a sense of the
most that we would send to the general
fund obviously I think between now and
the time these funds become three years
we'll be able to locate some more owners
so the money the the amounts may come
down a little bit but that's why you see
that drop it was a change in
procedure and then uh penalty
assessments again um we have seen just a
steady decline you see a zero in 2016
because again that money was actually um
going to police standards and training
so it was not hitting uh unrestricted
Revenue but as of 2017 it did and we
have seen a steady decline and penalty
assessments and I know I get asked every
year why I think that is um and it's I'm
sure it's a combination of things um it
may be you know raising the speed limit
in some parts of the state to 70 miles
an hour maybe less tickets are being um
issued as a result of that um are you
know as we are a fairly gray state are
we getting better behaved as we get
older I I don't know but um we just I
cannot obviously deny that there is a
general Trend here of declining
revenues and then the last Revenue that
we collect is the motor vehicle fines um
again if you have a f by mail that you
want to contest or you can't pay your
fine by ple by mail you have to pay it
at the court uh and we have seen again a
stady the CL even pre pandemic obviously
I think the the pandemic has affected
the number of vehicles on the road
significantly I think a lot of people
myself included are working from home
quite a bit so we have seen um you know
an impact to that Revenue stream as a
result of just more people being home
because of the
pandemic so our next slide then looks at
uh where we project uh revenues to be
for the through the end of this fiscal
year as as well as 22 and
23 and as I kind of alluded to I think
some of these revenue streams are more
vulnerable to the effects of the
pandemic event others um I think motor
vehicle type um amounts are going to be
more impacted you can see it and
defaults collected by safety and our
motor vehicle fines um safety is
projecting for fiscal year 21 $688,000
in revenues as opposed to they're around
800 plus thousand each year um bar exam
fees again I don't think is going to be
impacted all that much again e filing I
think will also be fairly immune because
it is online by
Nature um and then for fines I looked at
sort of a general trend for the last
three years to see what might be
happening in terms of it and I did the
same thing with fail forfeitures again
very difficult to predict on that one
entry fees I'm hoping will stay I again
uh I I just think we had a a severe hit
in the last quarter of fiscal year 20
but now I think we're we're kind of
going into an upward trend on that and
hopefully we'll stabilize in the next
year or two with that uh default fees
collected by the courts again little
tough to predict I'm looking at around
the 120 range to be
conservative uh other fees again that's
a lot of Records research which has
continued to be strong
so I'm actually looking at a fairly
healthy return on that um for this
fiscal year and there might be I'm
thinking maybe a little bit of a
downward Trend in 22 and
23 I just don't know I want I'd rather
be a little conservative to and see what
happens and be pleasantly surprised
rather than be too optimistic about uh
what those revenues may come in at and
then miscellaneous sales this is as I
talked about before what you're seeing
in 21 is as of today what's going to be
three years old in fiscal year 21 and
then for 22 around
$22,000 is going to be three years old
and then around 91,000 in fiscal year 23
those that's a maximum amount those
numbers will probably come down as I
mentioned as we find um owners of those
funds and then penalty assessments again
I think we're going to see a bit of a a
rebound I'm hoping um but the General
overall trend with Pas is that they are
coming down so I Tred to reflect that in
my 22 and 23 figures as well at some
point though it's got to bottom out I
just don't know where that bottom is
I've just seen it year overy year
continuing to decline but you would
think at some point you know it can't go
much further down if if people are if
police are giving out tickets and
assessing other fines for things again I
just I don't know enough about all the
drivers of that to to predict when it
may bottom out and then motor vehicle
fines again there's a a general Trend
downward um I'm hoping with fiscal year
21 again we're still seeing the impact
of the pandemic in 22 I've raised the
projection some of that I'm attributing
to backlog the courts have obviously
been challenged with um switching to
remote models to conduct their business
so there was a big culture change and a
lot of technology that had to be
implemented to allow us to do that um
but I think we're in a much better place
to conduct our business but we still
have a lot of catch-up to do so there is
quite a bit of backlog of cases and so
I'm hoping that we will see an uptick in
revenues that follow the ability of the
courts to process those cases and get
the revenue in but then I think
ultimately once we get done with that
backlog we're probably going to see a
little bit of a decline again in
revenues and that's why you see a
difference between 22 and
23 and then the last page um is just
foot about this I think most of them I
talked about but just to help explain
what what some of that revenue is about
um and how it's distributed so if the
committee has any questions um direct
ping and I will be happy to answer
them well thank you Donna very good
committee I do not see any raised
hands well right on time oh
right uh
represent
Mary did you have a question yeah um
thank you Mr chairman um if I could just
ask quickly Donna about your slide
related to the
waivers um you said that you've noticed
that there's a bit of an increase in
waivers being granted by judges could
you speak a little bit about the
year-to-year trends that you're seeing
I think that is more anecdotal um it's
what we've heard from judges in their
experience so I don't actually have data
for that and I'm it's very difficult to
um record that because we need to see
what the actual sign was and that that
information may be in our Odyssey case
system but I'm not sure that it gets
down to that level of granularity um but
it it tends to make sense um that you
know the more you start asking the for
you know payments the more people are
going to come forward and say I can't
afford this but I just wanted to put it
out there that it it is part of the
dynamic of uh revenues that we end up
questions then I thank uh both Donner
and and Christopher for a presentation
on the judicial branch thank you we're
right on time so we can start with the
and Karen rounds the chief financial
presentation good afternoon everyone I'm
GNA go ahead and share my
screen and and Karen did you send over a
copy of your slides or I did I sent it
over to Chris yesterday morning um so
I'm not sure if he sent that out via
email or uh has posted it to the website
maybe he could chime in and just let you
know that it is on the
website so all the presentations that
you have scheduled today and tomorrow
should all be on our
website
okay great and I will just apologize in
advance you will hear uh background
noise here I am at the state's emergency
Operation Center so uh you will hear
background noise um so this presentation
uh does not Encompass all of the
revenues for DHHS for a number of
reasons uh one um we have over 200
Revenue sources the largest of which
being the uh the Medicaid Program uh
which is in various accounting units all
across our department um and then like I
said there's over 200 total between
small grants that there are 10 you know
tens of thousands of dollars to larger
grants that are tens of millions of
dollars like the state OPI response
Grant um I did two years ago say that we
were working on a report to show you all
of those restricted Revenue sources uh
covid has as you can imagine put a um a
bit of a damper on many of our longer
strategic planning projects and we
unfortunately did not have that
completed for this vium but I am hoping
for next one when uh Co is hopefully in
our distant past so this um report here
uh that I had prepared for you shows a
number of things on this first section
that I'm showing you here on the screen
on the left hand side is a chart of the
actuals and the right hand side is the
chart of the budget note that it doesn't
line up perfectly as far as uh um just
sort of following the chart because the
actuals ends at at fiscal year 20
because we are currently in fiscal year
21 and the budget goes through to fiscal
year
23 a couple of things to note here um is
that you do see decreasing unrestricted
Revenue over the past several years the
reason for that is a change in the uh
manage care contracts that the
department has which are the contracts
that manage our Medicaid Program and
that those contracts change the way um
that the uh recoveries are managed and
that the mcos the manag Care
organizations are required to manage
those recoveries within their work which
results in a savings on the contract to
the state but also a decrease in the
amount of unrestricted Revenue so that's
really what you see reflected here what
I'd also note here is that um one thing
that's not included in the DHHS
unrestricted Revenue but is included in
the other unrestricted Revenue um on
your overall unrestricted Revenue sheets
are the restaurant fees so um we do
provide estimates on that to uh the
governor's office and to the LBA but
those are not included in the line
that's labeled DHHS unrestricted
Revenue um there's a couple of pie
charts here just for visuals uh if you
want to take a look at those later the
other thing that we have here is all of
the revenue sources
um sorry over the uh past several years
um and you will see like we talked about
that decline in the recoveries happening
over the past several years because of
the change in the contracts otherwise
our other revenues and unrestricted
stable on this page um just to let you
know what's in the other unrestricted
revenues as you can see it is a various
amount of small fees um and
expenditures there is also um just a
chart showing you again the unrestricted
revenues of that 1.2 million that's
various that that has decreased a little
bit over time but not
substantially there's also on this last
page a description of each of the
revenue sources so I know this has been
very high level I'm going to go ahead
and just scroll back up to the first
page because I think these two charts
are probably the most helpful in your
analysis um I also have several people
on the line who are familiar with each
of the revenue sources who can provide
more information um so I'm going to go
on mute for a few moments because I know
that I do have a ton of background noise
here and give you guys a second just to
look at it and see if there are any
questions representative major I muted
you I thought you were talking I'm sorry
[Music]
yourself representative major I muted
you I I thought you were on a phone call
elmy unmute
Susan I'm muted sorry um I can't figure
out how chart one relates to chart two
the budget doesn't seem to be the same
as the unrestricted
Revenue it's different numbers yep the
chart on the left is the actuals um the
chart on the right is the budget so
actuals have tended to Trend a little
bit higher than what we've budgeted with
the exception of um
2018 and 19 um if you look we came in at
about six million it was budgeted at 9
million that was a budgeting error that
year um last year in fiscal year 20 the
actuals were about 4.8 million and you
3.7 and in fiscal year 21 we are
trending to um to receive at least what
is budgeted if not a little bit more uh
you know there's a there's a joke that
that's not a joke but it is that you
occasionally hear that in HHS um a half
a million dollars is a rounding error uh
and so for us um you know this coming in
where it is and like I said where you
expect this will be a little bit higher
um but it's not like tens of millions of
dollars higher maybe it'll be a couple
hundred
thousand you said that in
2018 the budgeted amount was
wrong what would it
be it should have been closer to this we
probably would have budgeted it at about
5 million um it came in at about 6
million
that was uh that
was uh a double budgeting issue that we
made when we submitted the governor's
budget that was not caught through the
phases part of the recoveries are
actually federal funds it's not just
general funds so we recover twice the
amount but we have to return a portion
of that to the federal government so 19
be the same case too right yes it was 18
and 19 that that budget error was made
that those were both budgeted at 9 .1
6.2 all right strange that you would
okay uh further questions representative
Elliot yes uh Mr chairman I was
wondering I could hear Karen's voice and
I could also hear a man's voice I'm
getting two voices on my computer has
no sir that's me I'm sorry I'm at the
state's emergency Operation Center
you're hearing Perry plumber in the
background with the commissioner I'm
sorry about that thank you Karen that
explains
Aly you have to unmute Susan sorry I
just wanted to point out that
representative Murphy had a question
about the uh distribution of the net
money and we were told that maybe this
afternoon she could deal with
it yes I'm going to go ahead and stop
sharing and allow uh Chris to bring
Meredith um and Brooke into the
conversation because they are better
suited to answer your questions on that
than I am mine would be the 100,000 foot
View and they can certainly give you the
view before you do that could you send a
corrected or what it's supposed to be to
replace that graph we on 18 and 19 or it
shows you said it wasn't at 9.1 but it
was
closer no so it that is actually
representing the amount that was
budgeted we just budgeted it incorrectly
okay
go
ahead all right I see Brooke and
Meredith have joined so if you want to
go ahead and ask her question I think
we'll be good you want me ask the
question again yes oh this is Jim Murphy
thank you um my question was it was more
of a historical question as to where and
where we stand now regarding dish met
payments I remember when this started 30
years
ago um it was meant to obviously help um
those hospitals that took care of a lot
of um uh charity care or Medicaid
patients that weren't
paying the rate to for cost of the
patient in the hospital and initially my
understanding was
that for every dollar say in met tax the
government or the state of New Hampshire
would receive another dollar from the
fed and then that same dollar would go
back to the hospitals so for about 10
years it was really a a zero sum game
for hospitals but I think that has
slipped and I was just wondering if you
have this information what percentage of
met actually does return to hospitals
for care of indigen patients and
Medicaid
patients good afternoon representative
uh I'm Meredith tus with the Department
of Health and Human Services and happy
to answer your question you're quite
right in that historically that was the
mechanism the state used um and today we
are operating the Met dish program under
a settlement agreement with our
hospitals um and according to that
settlement the hospitals in total not
each Hospital specifically but in total
in aggregate 26 hospitals not including
the rehab hospitals receive back
91% of the amount that they pay in
met so as you noted the state receives
the Met it is matched with federal
dollars and then they would receive back
91% of the amount that they paid so to
make it real simple um they would pay in
uh $1
million thank you y absolutely
you have a further question
representative
Murphy one of them was and I think it's
been somewhat of a contentious issue
among the 26 hospitals as to the uh
allocation of the Dish payment and I was
wondering if that formula is is becoming
more refined or changing going forward
um or is there any real change in the
monies or are you asking what's the
percentage difference between the less
paid Hospital versus the highest paid or
or simply trying to match the um the
Dish payment to hospitals relative to
their um care of either Medicaid
patients or charity care or no pay type
patient so I was just wondering if there
is any change in the way it's being
allocated going forward or is this the
same
formula H S the formula yes thank you
for the question the the formula has
changed I'll say as the federal
definition
um changed however currently under our
settlement agreement we have uh defined
with the hospitals the amount that they
will receive back in met and so they
receive that amount back that 91% I
referred to whether it's made as a Dish
payment or another form of Medicaid pay
payment M so they will still receive
back the same amount even if the
definition of uncompensated care changes
which it has over the
questions Chris wasn't there another
HHS there was a question related to the
up representa
elmy thank you I actually had an
question related to the previous answer
hi Meredith it's really good to hear you
again anyway on you two
representa we used
to to give them back everything they'd
got and then use
they paid and then use the excess around
until the feds told us we couldn't um
use it around uh Medicaid and such and
is the current 9% Surplus also put into
General attempts to keep up our Medicaid
obligations yes that's used in our
account I think I better um give way to
Edith before I asked my question about
again so you're all through represent
Aly I have a second question but I
thought representative Tucker had her
hand up before I remembered nursing home
I don't see her her hand up her hand is
up I can see
it she's asking me to to to do the
question about nursing homes first
okay but I think we got actually I
remember now we got that
answered okay I see representative
unmute I'm going to ask a more amorphus
question up here in the North Country
particularly we hear a lot uh from
families and from
communities from Selectmen about people
who aren't being fully
served and it's always hard to know
trying to match the revenues and the
needs how do we know as legislators or
how do we know as Goodwill citizens of
New Hampshire that our most vulnerable
people are in fact being served that
there is enough
Revenue I it's a huge agency with a
tremendous number of
responsibilities so how how would if you
were a legislator what would you look
question I think that the best um place
for those types of questions is really
the Health and Human Services oversight
committee the commissioner regularly
attends that meeting
um you know my perspective is mostly
from a finance perspective and not from
a programmatic perspective where the
commissioner um you know really has an
overview of program and finance right to
be able to answer that question um so I
I think that that committee is probably
best for that type of question so how
often does the oversight committee
meet uh Chris I'm not sure if you
remember but I want to say it's at least
once a month it's on Fridays um and I
don't remember the EXA time I I don't
careen remember exactly I know they meet
I think it's monthly as correct but I
also think they meet as needed so there
may be times of the year where they do
frequently I think the pandemic has
taken its toll and people are very
worried so thank you very much
understandably you're
welcome Karen
uh is there any reason
why somebody from your department
couldn't ask that question of
them and get that information for the
committee um we we certainly can do that
I just I I'm just concerned that it's
not the best
um I'm just concerned about the context
I I think that the oversight committee
is the better committee to discuss that
but certainly uh if we um maybe if
representative Tucker you don't mind
putting the question in writing I can uh
bring it to my commissioner and provide
questions do you have anything else uh
commissioner all I'm sorry I am I am
thankfully not the commissioner of the
department Chief Financial
Officer uh but thank you um no I do not
have anything else but if anyone has any
follow-up questions pleas please do feel
free to reach out to me I'm I'm happy to
questions all right there's no other
hands then we have about seven minutes
before the next
presentation and we thank you Karen and
and the others for the information you
did provide to the committee you're very
welcome I do have a reputation of
talking a little fast through
presentations so uh I'm glad you got six
minutes back but I hope that um I didn't
confuse anyone so thank you
again you're
welcome all right we will be back at two
o'clock could I ask you a question uh
yes do you expect that we're going to be
voting on any bills on
Thursday it depends if we have any bills
that uh it's clearcut that we're all in
agreement on
yes if uh if not we won't
be so they'll be divided into three
areas the first area if it's clearcut
that we have an agreement on to either
itl or pass as is without any Amendment
we'll do it and then pass but with an
amendment then we'll have to wait for
the
amendment the other
is is is it something that it's in it's
really we it's interesting but we don't
have enough information and we need more
retain good and the other one the other
one
is if everybody agrees uh to itl fine or
ought to pass and the other the last
category is one
that we have part of the committee agre
one way and P the committee agrees the
other
way um it might be one we might want to
handle as a committee as a whole before
we make a decision one way or the other
so it's up to the the people that do the
presenting to convince everybody to to
go for it or or their presentation says
hey everybody wants to kill this
or all right
thank you
yeah and then there'll be those that um
let's say there's different opinions on
both sides we won't exact that right
away we give an opportunity for the
caucuses to be able to meet and discuss
and then maybe we might be able to work
something out between the
caucuses okay thank you very much are
general
questions
um looks like a good amount of people on
Thursday will be doing it virtually
which which I feel is probably
better and those that will be appearing
we're going to meet in room 206 208
it'll be combined into one
room on Thursday those
that decide that they want to
person tomorrow will be similar to today
shorter see we got five
here Mr Glennon is here just so you
know Mr Mr Glennon the new the director
of Securities Bureau just okay you be
aware of that that's all okay okay so
tomorrow we're going to hit from the
insurance department at
9 from from the Department of Safety at
10: Department of Transportation at
11: fishing game at
11:30 then at one o'clock the department
of administrative services
Department after we get through with the
agency head for this turn around then
we're going to start getting into the
work the meat of our work and go into
work sessions and then go through these
revenue streams one by
one and what I'm
anticipating and I hope it happens that
way is is that
everybody the new as well as those that
have been on the committee for a while
participate because as we go
through looking at each of these
revenues we'll end up wanting to know
what is your opinion on this particular
Revenue what do you think the range will
be so everybody should be able to
contribute what they think their range
is is going to be based upon everything
that they've heard from the economists
and from the agency heads or wherever
else and that way uh we get the most
broadest amount of information to
consider uh it seemed to have worked in
the past and then we'll look at the
ranges and make a decision of how we
want to come up with the final
decision but you want to be prepared to
defend why you think it's going to go
this high or that
low so don't think you're going to be
just a member of the committee to listen
you want you want to listen but you you
want to make a contribution to it too
that's the only way you really get to
learn because it forces you to ask the
question have two more minutes any
further
questions I do Norm representative
Tom Tom you're muted I'm getting there
Jen I'm getting there I'm not I'm a
yellow person paper person sorry okay we
we still good or
you're
good thank you Norm uh what door do we
come in and at the
lob
uh the side door or front yes please let
me know the um the front door the L you
can't come in because there's
construction going on you can come in
through the side door or through
the the parck back entrance okay now you
could also come in from the Park Street
entrance on into the state house and
then through the tunnel but it okay time
you come
in uh if you come into the State House
there'll be a guard there they'll do the
screening and then you can proceed into
the tunnel if you come into Park Street
into the
lolb uh you will be screened by uh One
Security the same way as if you come
through the parking lot okay
thank you
o'clock and good we have be U Barry
Glennon the director
from Security Bureau of the of the
Department of State and Barry it's your
time now if you want to share your
screen
go
[Music]
ahead maybe he's
muted
no can you uh hear me uh representative
major yes I can terrific all right see
you too oh you
great progress
I'm literally just right over here at
the uh Annex Building um but it seems
like we're tens of miles away when it
comes to uh technology so I'm glad we
came through I wasn't so successful with
uh the Commerce Committee uh last week
so I'm really excited at this point they
we're all new at this so yes yes that
was reminded of that by representative
hunt um he was very forgiving well thank
you uh very much um Mr chair uh for in
inviting me uh to uh present this
afternoon regarding Bureau of Security's
uh Revenue um and projected Revenue um
you know well into uh
2023 uh I thought it might be helpful
for some of the newer members um Mr
chair uh who may not necessarily be
acquainted with the bureau just to give
a very very brief um 50 slide
presentation on the bureau I'm just
kidding just a very brief presentation
about uh the bureau and then I think
that'll help put in proper context uh
the uh Revenue sources uh that we have
um and then certainly uh answer any
questions that the committee may have um
if if I may I'd like to uh share uh the
screen here to just kick off I believe
that uh uh Christopher also has provided
and uploaded these um to uh to the
committee uh so they could be uh viewed
online uh or shared on online let me
just expand this out and uh I'll be with
you just one second here we go you're
seeing that now in full screen hey
you're better at this than some others
all right well you're able to put it on
and then expand it all right very little
practice here my wife actually did a
tutorial with me yesterday she's a
teacher she's teaching remote well
partly well um the Bureau of Securities
regulation is organized under uh the
Secretary of State's office I report to
to secretary
Gardner responsible for the uh
regulatory oversight of broker dealers
investment advisors uh as well as the
registration of Securities that are sold
in the state of New
Hampshire uh our major functions again
very quickly are licensing of of these
entities uh the registration of
Securities we're also responsible for
conducting uh unannounced in-person
exams of the branch offices of these
firms uh throughout the state we also
have an investor education uh function
which is written right into the statute
where we go out and and meet with
members of the public and also on radio
or television to help promote investor
protection and investor safety uh and
then perhaps our most important role is
uh the enforcement component that is
enforcing ours
421b um and it is really through the
enforcement that is really one of the
one of our sources of revenue it's not
general fund Revenue however we are a
self-funded agency um with a staff of 12
so we do rely upon finds and penalties
that are derived from enforcement
actions uh to uh fund our
operation uh in terms of our overall
volume of activity uh we have there
approximately 1,200 uh licensed broker
dealers that we oversee more
surprisingly uh over 118,000 registered
Representatives licensed to do business
in New Hampshire and just as a point of
clarification they're not all residents
here in New Hampshire that would be
about the population of Manchester but
they are uh licensed to solicit into the
state of New Hampshire which which is
what triggers the license and very some
very some somehow your voice drops to
almost nothing oh comes back up
okay maybe I'll I'll try to to speak a
little bit louder okay okay um and then
in terms of investment advisors as you
can see roughly 2,300 investment
advisors uh and of course they're agent
Representatives they perform a slightly
different function than broker dealers
um uh which I can explain but perhaps u
in the interest of time uh we'll jump
into some of the more salian parts um in
terms of our audits uh they're very
thorough uh we do only charge $100 per
uh per day per examination of firms uh
however um it's it's fair and reasonable
in relation to other states uh but we do
have a two full-time Auditors out there
during pandemic we've had to Resort more
towards uh desk audits uh simply because
uh the firms have been uh hesitant to
have anyone inside and then many of them
are actually working remotely
uh enforcement is as I said is is a
significant source of uh revenue for
operating the bureau uh but also the
most active component with you know at
least 70 complaints and 40 enforcement
actions annually uh we also have
administrative hearings at a hearings
officer uh and then um we're also a
source of information for the public in
in terms of questions they may have
about maybe lost uh stock certificates
or uh just general questions about their
Investments so we perform that more
significantly though and I think the
purpose uh uh Mr chair of course of our
meeting today is to talk about uh securi
Revenue um and as you would had asked
the five-year uh summary of Revenue as
you can see from the chart here there
really there are two primary uh buckets
of of of Revenue first is broker dealer
investment broker dealer and investment
adviser fees and the second being
Securities registrations now I can
certainly explain both uh broker dealers
and investment advisor fees those are
the firms that do business in the state
as well as the
118,000 agent Representatives so we
derive a fair amount of revenue from
that Source uh as you can see in uh 2020
uh it was 16.6 million um over the
course of five years it has uh increased
significantly uh I would attribute that
uh growth over that period really due to
a booming uh economy as well as uh just
overall Investments as people may have
seen in their own 401ks and Iris uh
there's been significant growth with
regard to broker dealers and their
representatives uh same for uh
investment
advisers however on the Securities
registration side as you can see there's
been a bit of a fluctuation over the
past 5 Years From 2016 to 2020 ranging
anywhere from 24 to $29
million uh this is largely due to Market
fluctuations uh and the offering of
private Securities products uh it's
really part of the whole Capital
formation activity where companies are
going out uh to raise money or they're
not raising money uh or there's uh been
an expansion in terms of entrepreneurs
uh seeking to raise Capital whenever
they do that they have they're making a
public public offering they have to
actually file with the state the
offering that that they intend to
solicit and sell in state so that has
varied also mutual funds are a component
a significant component I might add in
terms of Securities registrations uh we
have well over 22,000 mutual funds that
are registered in New Hampshire which is
not unusual with uh in comparison to
other states because most funds will
offer in all 50 states uh that number
does vary and I do see a slight decrease
uh coming into uh
2022 uh for that
reason uh also there have been changes
on the federal level with regard to
mutual funds uh it's known as the
regulation bi best interests and what
that is is that um any kind of let's say
401K plans whenever they offer mutual
funds within the plan itself the rule
now is that you have to Pro provide
products that are in the best interest
of the customer and oftentimes best
interest means the lowest rate uh fund
lowest cost fund and so we've seen a bit
of a contraction in the mutual fund
industry where they've eliminated some
of the higher fee mutual funds and going
with more of the reduced fee you know 50
basis points 100 basis point type funds
so there's been a slight reduction in
mutual fund filings but it does
fluctuate as I said and I do anticipate
uh recovery and Co has been a factor as
well with with certainly with the
overall Securities
filings uh and I I'm hopeful for a
recovery I'm actually most certain of of
that that it'll occur in each of these
two
categories um as far as the
certification fees um that you can see
in the column that was eliminated by the
legislature was rule they were called
Rule 506 offerings uh Securities
offerings uh renewal Fe fees were
charged that was eliminated by uh the
legislature um back
in six 18 I believe six no 17 uh and
then Bell bondsman there's been a steady
decrease in that which is a really small
source of Revenue we do regulate bail
bondsmen uh however with bail reform a
number of The Bondsmen have actually
left the industry and I think we're only
down to two bail bondsman uh throughout
the state which is unfortunate but that
has been you know a result of Court
reform and and changes in in bail
statutes so as far as overall projected
Revenue as as you can see um I uh
anticipate that uh we will uh end 2021
at approximately 41.
uh250 uh million do uh and then an
increase over uh the next two years uh
as we see more broker dealers coming
back postco uh opening more Branch
offices registering more uh registered
representatives and investment advisors
uh so that contraction I I I believe is
just temporary due to people registered
Representatives leaving the industry uh
and maybe working from home and deciding
it's really not working and leaving not
re-registering uh but returning so the
picture uh does look look better uh as
we go forward um and I believe that that
um Mr chair is essentially uh uh uh a
review of what we see for Revenue uh
coming forward this year as well as the
next two fiscal years and I'd be happy
committee thank you Barry for your
presentation and we have questions from
the
Ames
you'll have to unmute D I've got it um
so thank you for that good presentation
um so my question is about enforcement
actions and uh you mentioned those are
significant I I assume a significant
activity in your department or agency
and um I wondered if you could provide
us with an example or two of sort of the
major kinds of enforcement actions that
you'd be engaged in and what kind
money's involved certainly they they
really do range um uh in in terms of the
types of cases that we typically see
it's really the sale of products that
are not suitable for the particular
investor um there are sometimes where
agents agent Representatives May engage
in activity that is not appropriate in
other words they may do what we call
churning where they're overtrading the
account they're constantly uh selling
mutual fund or or proposing one for the
purchase and then the sale of it in a
very short time period and then then
recommending another another product and
again they get a commission each and
every time they do that that's called
churning and um it's it's uh not allowed
it's really not a suitable sales
practice whatsoever um there's also
fraud that occurs licensed individuals
but more so that we see those who are
not licensed they may have been in the
industry at one point uh they left the
industry however they never bothered to
tell their clients that or or they sell
products that are very
speculative over the internet again on
an unlicensed
basis and uh ultimately results in you
know significant losses and in terms of
the victims that that we see uh they can
really vary um it could be uh an elderly
couple um that has uh maybe
$100,000 let's say in their overall
savings uh that was uh squandered and
and swindled Away by someone some
unscrupulous uh person uh and then we
have at the opposite end of the range
some that are relatively wealthy
individuals um who are likewise often
sometimes sometimes not always taken
advantage of I think probably the most
uh interesting case that we've had this
year this fiscal year actually involved
uh former former uh New Hampshire
Governor uh Craig Benson where um he
experienced difficulty with uh his
brokerage firm and that resulted in the
return of well
over I think it was maybe 22 million
back to uh uh to the governor who was a
victim in in this case so it really does
range we I mean uh uh not to boast but
I'm very proud of of what the bureau
does and I can just tell you
representative that that we make sure
that the same attention is afforded to
the individual that lost Maybe we might
consider a small sum as a in even the
larger uh losses as well we treat them
equally uh because it represents their
assets it represents their livelihood
and their retirement many of many cases
their
retirement thank you so much that's very
helpful to have a picture of what you're
doing thank you representative
Mary a
[Music]
can thank you Mr here it's um
representative Mary hecken Phillips here
and I was just wondering um let's see
Barry I remember you said at the outside
of your presentation that there were two
Auditors maybe you could give the uh
committee a sense of how many um staff
members are within the bureau and then
how many of those staff members are for
uh designated for enforcement purposes
sure we have uh we have two full-time
Auditors actually first start we have a
staff of 12 and that starts from the
receptions to me um so there are two
Auditors and then we also have five
staff attorneys who are assigned to uh
the enforcement unit uh because and
their attorneys because uh we are
dealing with you know essentially
lawyers when we file an action against
broker dealer firm uh more often than
not they're hiring some of the big guns
as I might call call them some of the
larger firms even you know local firms
firms International firms that represent
some of these uh larger broker dealers
and investment advisors so it the
process has evolved over the years
certainly uh far more litigious uh in
terms of their defense of their clients
uh so we really do need to have you know
trained and seasoned lawyers uh to uh
address these uh
cases if I could just ask a quick
followup with that um what is the
coordination on the federal level from
the state you know in terms of
proceeding with these enforcement
actions what kind of yes um actually
it's a very very good question and I I I
hope hopefully I won't confuse uh the
committee on this but there are really
three levels in terms of Securities
regulation in the US we're all
acquainted with the SEC uh the SEC is
essentially the overall federal
government overseer of the markets uh
and of those who sell products uh
throughout the country so the SEC is
primarily focused on the large public
companies their public filings uh as
well as some of the major cases they
very rarely and I say I should really
kind of couch my remarks I don't want to
overstep here but they they rarely do
not engage with some of the smaller
investors on the state level they
relegate that really to the indiv 50
state Regulators so we tend to take more
of the local type actions um where that
involved New Hampshire investors the
intermediary is called finra uh which is
a self-regulatory organization that
broke a dealers must belong to it's a
member based organization uh it's really
kind of a subset of the SEC they're
overseen by the SEC uh but they're
they're a bit of an intermediary but
they're not a state or federal regulator
uh more of a private regulatory
organization that it's it's a bit
different uh but it does exist so
there's really three levels of of
Regulation now the Bureau of Securities
is a member of the North American
Securities administrators I'm the voting
member and member of a chair of one of
their committees and we as a as an
organization will act uh in many cases
uh on a global basis we will uh look at
firms on a na Nationwide scale and
coordinate our efforts uh when examining
a particular firm or taking an
enforcement action against firm uh and
that's how there's also various other
functions common training you know when
we can uh travel a lot of it is done by
way of Zoom nowadays but we do
participate nationally uh in that regard
uh and of course the New England
Regulators we have our own group uh and
we coordinate our actions because we're
such in in New England we're so close to
each other it's really important that we
talk to each other because often times
uh there are Bad actors that are
crossing state into into Maine into
Vermont into Mass to Rhode Island
respect are you all
set representing Phillips okay
next is represent
Alan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question Mr Gleason I have
two questions one is the document that's
up on your screen
share in the middle of it you show um
year-to-date
actuals and the year is 50% over and the
revenue is just over 10% what was
projected is that typical is everything
that waited to the third and fourth
quarter of the fiscal year it is uh the
uh fourth quarter and then well first
and fourth quarter and and
representative it's a very good point as
you can see 2021 only showing
uh 2.2 million thus far however this
this this revenue is reflected through
December
31 it does not reflect January revenue
we will see an enormous infusion uh in
January as you can see just on the
broker dealer side they all Renew on
January one of each year so we will
easily see uh somewhere around $13
million alone just with broker dealers
that will flow that will be reflected uh
in January
and then Securities registrations which
right now are showing only 252,000
we will see at least um 22 million flow
in from Mutual Funds uh during the month
of March and April uh of this year so
that's uh that it doesn't give you a
complete picture actually as far as what
we will see come May uh so there are two
big Revenue um increases is in January
and April
May thank you that answer very
comforting yes comforting to me
too uh and Mr chair I have a second
question with your permission go ahead
you had mentioned that uh some of the
revenue is derived from Mutual Funds
being operate in retirement plans yes
and just as as a Layman it it seems like
there's some kind of migration going on
right now from mutual funds to
ETFs it is is that perception correct
and will that affect Revenue going
forward do we collect the same amount of
is there some type of fee associated
with an
ETF that corresponds to yes we we do uh
we do collect on uh ETF type
filings um the it's been a gradual
progression uh towards uh exchange
traded funds and just for for the
ification of of the committee uh
exchange traded funds the price itself
per share uh or the net asset value can
change from minute to minute based upon
the trading activity unlike a mutual
fund where the value of the share is set
at the concl at the conclusion of the
trading day so ETFs are more it's really
a collection of stocks that exist within
the fund but that they can be rapidly
traded throughout the day and they can
fluctuate value so um some ETFs have
been performing really quite well
they're very popular um and I I can't
say anything really negative about them
um uh other than the fact that there is
a an additional risk when you do
purchase them because the value can
fluctuate okay thank you for your
response I appreciate it uh do we have
questions
we don't there's no more hands raised
so Barry we thank you for your
presentation give us a lot to chew on
chair all right so it is
now 2:24 so we've got six minutes for
the next
presentation and thanks Barry thank
you
go any questions for
me when we get through today I'll be get
in touch with u Chris and we're going to
talk about work sessions
and which we definitely will have
one maybe two next week which would be
on Tuesday and possibly
Wednesday
Thursday we're going to do bills
again which I say again because we
haven't done them yet until this
Thursday
but Thursday the
4th also Thursday the
11th
and then
revenues around the
16th of
February and after the Governor presents
his budget want to sit down have
Governor's budget director sit down with
us and we go over his
revenues and so that
he so that we can understand what his re
revenues consist
of
because we project our revenues strictly
on current law his revenues would might
be a combination of current law
and
changes
uh and proposed legislation that he has
in his budget so we'll get that square
away and then we want to close through
the
uh end of April I mean February we want
to come out with the revenues so we can
give them to the uh finance
committee
that's what we're planning on doing
so tomorrow I should be able to announce
we definitely going to have work
sessions on Tuesday and possibly
week um also we need to make up our mind
whether the work sessions are going to
be complete
virtual
or
like
we're doing um
our public
hearings
so hopefully I can give you that
information
tomorrow i' really love to have uh the
work
sessions in person
but under the
it any questions from anybody Mr chair
did you mention um that you thought we
would be holding a public hearing on um
Wednesday
oh
I I didn't even take that into
account um if we
o'clock Mr chairman I believe that we've
held sessions on Ash Wednesday quite
frequently
well
I'd like to be able to be flexible and
to be able to uh come up with something
that the majority of the Committees are
to representative
um Phillips is it all right if I just
call you representative
Phillips um I think my parents would be
really sad if I was not not addressed by
their uh name as well so it it's helpful
if it's helpful my last name is hacken
like a computer hack oh
okay um I know that double k is a little
confusing but it just think of a
computer hack and my last name is hacken
Phillips
pretty well you help me good okay
represent hackin Phillips
um you would not be able to attend if it
was on the 17 no I was just trying to be
considerate of my colleagues
here
uh would it be better if we started at
10: rather than
nine anybody else have any any
concern why don't you just send me a an
email or
um or give me a phone call if you're got
a preference of when to start on the
17th Mr chairman yes
um traditionally we lutherans have it
the worship at night I I I don't know
whether Mary is thinking about going to
church at nine o'clock in the morning or
maybe she goes to a Catholic church I
don't
know is that why you again guys I just
wanted to bring up the issue in case
anybody else had a conflict so please
don't plan around me thank you yeah okay
you have a conflict let me know please
fine okay um if 9 o' is fine just raise
your
uh okay um if nine o'clock is not
fine then raise your
hand
any okay then we put that question to
bed right great so we'll meet at
nine yes okay thank you yeah there's one
more thing that has to be accomplished I
have to get a hold of Aaron he just sent
me an email as he had he had misplaced
the uh email I sent him relative to what
we wanted to
days and so I'll let you
know okay it is
232 and we can go on to our final
presenter for the
day and he's in already has a
panelist thank you so who we have today
is Edward S sis or
session Sis Sis Edward sis and he's the
Assistant Attorney General from the
Department of Justice and he's here to
talk
about the tobacco settlement Revenue
that we get and that usually runs
anywhere from 35 to 40 something million
dollars a year so it's
yours uh and you have a handout to
you I submitted a uh brief memo to um
Christopher Shay that um not sure if
that's circulated I I do not have
a a PowerPoint presentation that will go
up okay all
right so I have a copy of that uh if
Chris could make sure that a copy of
that memo gets mailed to the uh members
of their committee that'd be great we of
major that memo is on our website as
well okay aailable there if you want to
see it we if you'd like I can bring it
up during this meeting would you please
yeah I am not the most technologically
savvy person so I did not want to
attempt to share some sort of a
presentation
Crow there we go all
bigger can it be made there we go better
better okay I would Jo all right well
good afternoon uh as I was introduced my
name is Edward sis I'm an Assistant
Attorney General in the consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau at the
New Hampshire Department of Justice I'm
my job is the tobacco enforcement
attorney so I uh I'm here to talk with
you today about the tobacco Master
settlement agreement my understanding is
that there are some new committee
members maybe some people that are not
intimately familiar with the master
settlement agreement beyond what they've
seen in the news or were aware of things
that were going on 20 years ago we have
nine members there no yeah well that I'm
ready to uh to discuss some history
which will be of uh you know varying
degrees of interest to people and then
get to the part that um that you're
probably more interested in as quickly
as I can so I'm here to talk about the
tobacco Master settlement agreement
it'll be referred to as the MSA quite
frequently um in the 1990s several
States SU
the four largest tobacco companies to
recover taxpayer money that was being
spent to treat residents that had tobac
related illnesses there were a lot of
medical expenses in the states wanted
tobacco companies who they believed were
responsible for those costs to pay that
in 1998 52 States and territories
settled with the four largest tobacco
companies at the time and entered into
the master settlement agreement or MSA
over time 40 additional tobacco
companies have joined the MSA so what
was the purpose of the MSA it was to
reduce smoking in the United States
especially with youth so that's
something to keep in mind when you think
of the MSA the purpose of it was not to
uh create a ongoing stream of Revenue to
the states it was to reduce smoking
rates with the hope of eventually uh
eliminating smoking in the United States
uh this was accomplished by first
raising the cost of cigarettes with MSA
payments especially with youth if you
think about teenagers being very
responsive to prices as the price of
cigarettes go up teenagers would be less
able to afford cigarettes would never
start smoking as teenagers and would
hopefully never become adult
smokers restrictions in advertising were
part of the
MSA easy way to think of that is no more
Joe Camel no more Winston cup uh with
NASCAR no more large Billboards for
tobacco advertising and things like that
eliminating the practice of tobacco
companies obscuring health risks there
were uh groups like The Tobacco
Institute if you ever saw the movie
Thank You for Smoking or read the book
uh there's a fictional character in
there that works for the tobacco
companies they had these very large
well-funded research organizations that
produced huge amounts of research
showing that cigarettes were not bad for
you and created a lot of uh
misinformation so they're no long they
agreed to stop doing
that and then also funding educational
programs that are now known known as the
truth initiative to help educate
particularly young people about the
dangers of cigarette smoking and uh they
do this with commercials that you may
see on TV if you have uh younger
children you may these ads are targeted
so you won't see them on all media but
if you're watching youth programming
then you'll see these advertisements
they have websites they're very active
on social media trying to counter the
idea that young people have of smoking
being something that's positive and uh
they also get people that are they're
known as like ambassadors or something
like that that work on high schools and
College campuses basically trying to get
the message across that cigarettes are
still bad for you even if you're
watching you know Mad Men on Netflix and
it looks cool that D Draper smoking that
you should not start smoking that it was
going to cause you a lot of problems did
it work yes absolutely there's no
question the MSA performed as designed
between 1998 when uh the states and the
tobacco companies entered into the MSA
in 2019 you us cigarette smoking uh
declined by more than
50% and you can see this just by walking
around that you just see fewer people
smoking now than you did even you know
20 years ago so it's been a major
success uh even more importantly to to
our future because if people don't start
smoking as young people they will not be
adult smokers you don't hear about
people starting to smoke when they're in
their 30s or 40s it's people start when
they're teenagers so rates of high
school smokers it declined from a high
in 1997 of
36.4% so if you think about that over a
third of high school students were
smoking in the late 1990s and then 2019
it went to just just around 6% so that's
a a huge change in 20 years well 22
years so a big big difference and uh the
MSA is a big part of that with the big
increases in cigarette prices so so a
group that helps us with um all of this
is nag the National Association of
Attorneys General they have a center for
tobacco and public health so they work
with the settling states to preserve and
enforce the MSA so they have attorneys
and support staff that do various things
for the states and helping with the MSA
so they work with the settling States
the tobacco companies the independent
auditor who is a an accounting firm
price waterhous Cooper that they go
through this enormous amount of sales
data to figure out the payments to all
the states it's it's quite something
that they go through every year to
figure this out and it's why we don't
know the final number until the check
it's not even a check but when the wire
transfer goes through to the states
that's when we actually know because
they figure it down to the penny for how
much money you get and uh they represent
the settling States and bankruptcy
matters some of these tobacco companies
do go bankrupt and
us repres those Bank
hearings and between the states a big
part of my week uh calls
talk is my it's my internet connection
to hear
me it's getting
spotty ah I apologize I xinity has been
not so great um so they I talk with
Attorneys General at um their staff in
all of the settling States multiple
times a week to talk about how we're all
doing with uh tobacco matters so what
about tobacco companies that did not
join the MSA so not all tobacco
companies decided to settle with the
states some of these didn't exist at the
time some of them were small foreign
companies that came into the market
after who saw an opportunity now that
Philip Morris and RJ Reynolds are
writing these big checks that they
thought they could undercut them on
price so these are known as
non-participating manufacturers or npms
they usually focus on low cost
cigarettes they're known as tier 4
subgeneric cigarettes so if you're at
the convenience store grocery store you
typically aren't going to see these
cigarettes these are very very lowcost
cigarettes um if if you were to see them
they'd be on the very bottom shelf near
the
ground uh these are the lowest of
lowcost cigarettes so that's the market
that they are uh that they're targeting
so we have a separate law that the
legislature enacted RSA 541c that these
manufacturers have to comply with it was
designed to eliminate the price
advantage that they had over the
participating manufacturers so they are
required to deposit money into escrow
accounts it has to stay in there for a
minimum of 25 years it causes them to
lose some of their price advantage that
they could potentially have with the
participating
manufacturers and it ensures that
there's money there so if a state were
to file a lawsuit against them that they
couldn't uh declare bankruptcy and have
uh and be judgment proof so it protects
well so that's a major part of my job is
making sure that they're making those
escrow payments we have four active npms
in the state of New Hampshire if you're
curious they are Korean tobacco and jins
sing which is out of South Korea Grand
River Enterprises which is out of Canada
and we have two American companies oasi
and
Xcalibur which uh sell cigarettes in New
Hampshire there are many more npms out
there but we only have four that sell
here in New
Hampshire so you may be saying okay
that's enough what about the money so
since these payments began in 1999 New
Hampshire has received over
$952
million in payments so little New
Hampshire has gotten close to a billion
dollars over the course of the
MSA so since 2014 the payments have
ranged from a high of just under $46
million 45.9 million and then in 2018 is
the low at $ 41.4
million and what what impacts these
payments why do they vary so they adjust
upward based on inflation we're in a
non-inflationary environment right now
as you likely know but the agreement
calls for a minimum 3% inflation in the
payment so the inflation causes the
payment to go up each
year then they go down for other reasons
so the decrease in the National tobacco
market again remember the point of the
MSA was to decrease cigarette sales so
this is happening as designed so last
year the decline in sales was
Nationwide it's adjust into downward
again for npm sales as they increase so
those little companies I talked about uh
they're growing they started off as
close to 0% of the market and they're
gradually increasing as more consumers
uh decide to go with the uh cheaper
alternatives so they're switching from
premium cigarettes like you know the
Philip Morris products they're no longer
smoking maros as their finances change
they're going with lower and lower and
lower cost um options so as those
increase their sales the um the the
auditor looks at it and if they can see
that if they attribute the decrease in
the participating manufacturer sales is
related to that increase in npm sales
then there can be a decrease in the um
in the payment
and then the most important part of my
job is the non- diligent enforcement of
the statute so there's the SE paid
adjustment which is the state excise tax
so any cigarette that's sold in the
state of New Hampshire by an npm there
has to be a corresponding escrow deposit
made so I work with uh the folks over at
the Department of Revenue I make sure
that every cigarette that they've
collected tax on that there is an escro
payment made for it
there is a separate independent auditor
that goes over those results and if they
determine that we have not met Our
obligation then they can reduce the
payment uh that we receive so that has
not happened we've uh done a good job
making sure that escro payments are made
for all of these uh cigarettes sold and
our payment has not been
reduced so the recent trend is downward
as I said in
2018 just under $46 million 45 9 million
for the MSA payment in 2019 it was
44.5 million in 2020 42.6
million so the predictions moving
forward I've spoken with uh nag with the
tobacco council at nag their prediction
is that there's going to be a continuing
decline in overall cigarette sales and a
corresponding decrease in MSA
payments if you look at the the memo
there that uh is on the screen the
current estimate in 2021 payment is 38.4
million 2022 is 38.2 million and 2023 is
$3 36.3
million um they are hesitant to make any
adjustments at this time because we do
not yet know what the impact of covid-19
on cigarette sales is uh it could be
that people with more time on their
hands have increased their smoking and
that they are continuing to buy the
premium Brands it could be that they
have switched due to finances to lower
cost brands or if people switched to uh
vaping ecigarettes um other nicotine
products that are out there that are not
covered by the MSA these new nicotine
lenes or things like that or if they
decide they're going to take an
opportunity to quit smoking now that
would further decrease uh tobacco sales
in the MSA payments but we do not know
yet we'll when when the checks come
rolling in we'll get the final answer on
what the uh the impact was on Tobacco
sales in
2020 does anyone have any questions and
the checks uh come in when what month in
April let me get the actually have
up just give me one second I can pull up
the
calendar
I apologize that
is I had been thinking that is something
that I would have
that we need to come up with
revenues by the end of February
and then uh we'll look at them again by
the time that the house votes on the
budget and and sends it over to the
Senate and I doubt if we have the the
value of what the payment will be at
that point in
time the only time we'll be able to use
that is when we do the committee of
conference which will be in j June and
we deal with the
Senate but we're going to be looking at
our revenues again anyway at that point
in
time according to this that pulled up
it's April
22nd
year is that
it yes that that is all I have if anyone
has any questions I'm happy to uh do my
best to answer them and if if I need to
I can look it up and get back to uh the
committee if I don't have the answer
handy we have three lined up of
questions first is represent alen
Bernstein thank you Mr Sharon thank you
Mr Sison um my question it might be
better for Christopher Shay to answer
this or perhaps the chair or or Mr
listen what I'm doing is I'm comparing
your memo specifically the third
paragraph where we talk about where you
reference how much we've received in
2019 and 2020 and I'm comparing that to
the caffer page
146 and the uh the 2019 number ties to
the penny the 2020 number is is nowhere
close
um it it's showing just under 26 million
was collected in 2020 this is per the
caffer page 146 and I just can't
reconcile the difference between 42
million and 26 million uh Chris or Norm
can can anybody help me out here um I
don't know the answer to that question
represent burin but I I can look into
that and get back to the committee and
see why there's
difference seems like that 26 million is
way
off yeah it it it might just be a typo
if you look at the number uh per the
memo it's
42,5
199,000 it it looks like a digit was
dropped off of that so maybe it's just a
typo um anyway let's give Chris a chance
to take a look at it and Chris will get
back with that y I'll I'll get hopefully
I'll get something by the end of today
and so tomorrow I'll be able to answer
the question when you guys meet okay
okay am I still on yeah
uh so my question has to do with the uh
both the black market and vaping and uh
impact on uh trends
for uh
taxable sales of
cigarettes maybe uh any information you
have on that score would be helpful to
us yes so um ecigarettes as you know are
taxed in New Hampshire so sales of
ecigarettes vaping things whatever
terminology you want to use are taxed so
there is tax revenue coming in however
they are not underneath the master
settlement agreement so there is no MSA
payment that goes along with those um
with black market uh cigarettes there
then there would be nothing there would
be no tax revenue those would not be
part of the MSA um I've spoken with
people over at the uh Liquor Commission
who are out there looking for for it and
looking for Contraband and when they
find it it's confiscated and um and they
prosecute those that they find so New
Hampshire is making sure that we are
finding those and that there's not
illegal tobacco um something that to
keep in mind is that we have um compared
to our neighbors a lower uh cigarette
tax so there's less of an incentive for
people to break the law and bring non-
tax cigarettes into new h sure it would
not make a lot of sense unless they were
to go all the way down to Pennsylvania
all of the Northeast we have the lowest
cigarette tax so we would have the uh
the least incentive to why risk it why
risk breaking the law with us to it
wouldn't make any
sense okay before we go to the next
question uh Allan I looked up the
revenue Focus for June
of 2020 which is the of Fisco money and
the tobacco settlement money that came
in for that year which is 42.6 million
so it
must there's a problem there because the
focus shows
42.6
um rep major if I might yeah the answer
to the question is you're page 146 of
the cafer is only the general fund
portion
the first $40 million of the settlement
goes directly into the education trust
fund yes so there was
42 and change collected in the
settlement last year so you're seeing
the 2.5 million that went to the general
148 you'll see the $40 million for the
settlement wow education Chris thank you
you're welcome sorry didn't get it right
Bron this wasn't my original question I
I was want to ask Chris so what happens
this year if uh revenues go uh below 40
million how's that made up that's not my
question of the of the uh speaker so for
Chris so um represent brami the first
$40 million of the tobacco settlement so
goes directly into the education trust
fund so if there's a number less than 40
million it just all goes to the tobac
education trust fund it has to be made
up some benefit is when you get
something over 40 million then it drops
into the um general fund and you have
the ability to use it in other places in
the
budget okay thank you and the uh real
question is so in the tech that's coming
on
April that's and the formula that use
for that that check through for all the
states that participate in this uh is
based on the cigarette at sales in what
period is it calendar or calendar uh 20
or do you know it would be from S Sales
year
2020 calendar year 20 calendar yes sir
yeah yes so that would be mostly in the
uh uh the period of the covid N you know
three quarters of that year is co months
yes and this is something we've been
talking about I've I it's it's going to
be interesting to see what the impact is
and what changes in consumer Behavior
because it has been a complete change in
people's lives and every way so um no
one feels comfortable guessing what the
final outcome is going to be but we will
know okay than follow up on that is the
sale of the tobacco stamps in 2020
versus 2019 have you looked at that so
I've spoken with the Department of
Revenue uh they track um for for me the
npm sales so we track those very tightly
because of the escro requirements with
the um the participating manufacturers
so that they don't have those um the
reporting on that done so the the stamps
are purchased by wholesalers and the
certified stamping agents so those
aren't necessarily all applied they
weren't all applied in 2020 they could
have gotten some that
are still to be applied in
2021 but when they finish they will have
a final number on that but they do not
have it yet we're usually more concerned
manufacturers represent
Aly yeah and I do the does
sales on during calendar year 20 mean uh
sales that were completed to the
consumer or sales that were completed on
from the tobacco wholesaler where we tax
it which then would divide into those
that paid by Bond and hadn't paid yet
and the rest of
them so you're asking for sales that
factor into the MSA payment is that yes
yes I need to check on that I know for
escrow payment purposes it's when the
stamp is applied so it's when the
wholesaler sells them to the retailer
and applies a stamp at that point
they're considered
sold I do not know with certainty if
that is also when they get factored into
that and if I am getting back does make
a difference of a month of 2020 in terms
Co yes it would it it could make a
difference um when I get that answer
would I send it to um Christopher Shay
and then he would send that or how would
that get sent out you could send it to
us
further
questions saying no further questions I
I thank you very much for your
presentation and bringing everybody up
to speed on the history of the master
settlement
agreement thank you for having me have a
you all right uh members of the
committee do you have any questions of
me before we sign off and get ready for
tomorrow morning because I need to get
busy to get the
schedule could you repeat Mr chairman
the date of the budget hearing of the
hearing that you spoke of well we have
the hearings public hearings this
Thursday yes I knew that but then you
another one then
uh the 4th of
February the 11th of
February and the 17th of February great
it's enormously helpful I'm sure to me
to have these states and I'm sure to
others and and what I'm trying to work
out right now is the second and third of
February for work sessions and if we
might need
to and I should be able to tell you that
tomorrow thank you very
much I think this goes very smoothly I'm
impressed all right any further
questions if not then we'll see you
tomorrow morning for at nine o'clock and
thanks everybody for being very
attentive thanks Mom good job you thank
you thank you Mr
chairman hey Chris would you stay
on or Chris give me a call okay I'll